Chaosradio Teil 125. Deja vu, die Musik kenn ich doch. Das Chaosradio Jingle, wie jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat auf Fritz. Klar, jetzt auch heute hier zu hören. Von 22 bis 1 Uhr, also jetzt mittlerweile knapp nach 22 Uhr und optimistisch gesehen 8 nach 10, aber die Zeit sei Paul van Dyck gegönnt. Herzlich willkommen zum Chaosradio Teil 125. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz, ich grüße euch ganz herzlich. Wir reden wie immer im Chaosradio am Letzten Mittwoch auf Fritz über Dinge, die im weitesten Sinne mit digitaler Welt, mit Computern und sonstiger Technik zu tun haben. Zu Gast selbstverständlich der Chaos Computer Club, so auch heute, und zwar Annett Rebina, schönen guten Abend. Hallo. Und dann ist noch Thorsten Junge hier, hallo Thorsten. Und Frank Rosengart, hallo Frank. Hallo. Wir reden heute über Jugendschutz.
Aber es darf dir nicht verkauft werden.
Ja, also und dann jetzt eben zu der zweiten Sache generell. Und zwar erstmal die Regelung und so, die finde ich auch alle ganz gut. Und das ist ja in Deutschland alles ganz gut festgelegt, wie es sein sollte. Aber wie gesagt, das ist eigentlich überhaupt nicht so. Und du hast auch schon gesagt oder Lino am Anfang hat schon gesagt, mit im Laden gehen oder so oder irgendwo in Neukölln Spiel kaufen oder so, es ist dem Verkäufer egal. Ich brauche dafür eigentlich nicht mal nach Neukölln zu gehen oder so. Und zwar mit 13 darf ich ja schon ein Girokonto haben und das habe ich auch. Und ich bin damit bei Amazon angemeldet und die fragen gar nicht nach dem Alter. Also ich kann mir das Spiel auf 16 bestellen. Ich habe den nämlich noch gar nicht besprochen. Da dachte ich irgendwie weiß es noch keiner. Und da fragte man sich der Postbote und die fragen nicht nach dem Alter. Wenn ich jetzt sage, habe ich schon gemacht oder habe ich nicht, ist ja egal.
Bei Amazon wollen die keinen Altersnachweis?
Nee, ich habe mich da mal angemeldet, nicht um so ein Spiel zu kaufen. Ich bin ja jetzt nicht so ein Freak oder so. Nicht, dass ihr was Falsches denkt von mir. Aber um mir was anderes Kleines zu kaufen, haben die mir geliefert. Und dann irgendwann dachte ich mir, ja, mal gucken, ob die nach dem Alter fragen und haben sie nicht gemacht. Und ja, es kommt dann zwei Tage später, als ob du dir da ein Schachset bestellt.
Das ist interessant, weil es gibt natürlich eine Menge Merchandise oder Versandhäuser, wo man Filme, DVDs, Videos kaufen kann, die eindeutig darauf hinweisen, wenn es Geschichten gibt, die mit einer Altersfreigabe versehen sind, dass man da eine Ausweiskopie mitschicken muss. Wenn das bei Amazon nicht geht.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob das Beispiel ab 18 auch ist, aber ab 16 kann ich auf jeden Fall.
Also ich kenne es von 18er-DVDs, da muss man, wenn man die haben will, ein Altersnachweis mitschicken.
Ja, also keine Ahnung.
Das wäre doch mal ein Thema, wo man mal bei Amazon nachfragen könnte. Prima Idee, ich schreibe ihn mal auf, da frage ich demnächst gleich mal nach. So viel zum Thema, es muss alles verboten werden, weil Jugendliche werden versaut.
Es gibt ja schon auch die Bestrebungen, oder es gab zumindest jetzt den Wunsch oder die Idee von einigen Politikern, dann diese ganzen kritischen Spiele einfach ganz zu verbieten. Das heißt also nicht diese Altersfreigaben, sondern einfach sagen, gibt es nicht weg, darf nicht verkauft werden, am besten gar nicht hergestellt werden und geht alle zum Teufel, wir wollen eure Spiele nicht. Wäre denn das ein denkbarer Weg, um diese Spiele weg zu bekommen oder die eben gar nicht mehr zugänglich zu machen?
Da brauche ich jetzt nicht die anderen Hörer wiederholen. Ich habe genau dieselbe Meinung. Man kann es gar nicht verbieten. Es ist auch Unsinn, hatte ich ja vorhin auch gesagt, mit der Palette, die zutrifft. Ab wann jetzt so ein Spieler aggressiv wird dadurch und irgendwelche Gewalttaten begehen kann. Ich finde, dass diese Palette, was noch dazugehört, die ganzen sozialen Geschichten und so, das ist alles so breit. Und da nehmen die Spiele so einen kleinen Teil nur ein. Und wenn man die einfach verbieten würde, ja, was bringt es dann? Also, er würde sich trotzdem besorgen, wenn er dann die sozialen Probleme und so hat. Und ja, bringt überhaupt nichts.
Es gibt ja auch die Frage oder die These, dass sich besonders Kinder und Jugendliche, die sowieso schon ein sehr hohes Aggressionspotenzial haben, sich genau diese Spiele aussuchen. Würdest du dem eher zustimmen oder würdest du sagen, dass es da für dich erstmal keinen Zusammenhang gibt?
Doch, würde ich schon sagen, weil, keine Ahnung, es wird immer gesagt, es ist so ein Ventil für Wut oder für Druck. Also, das kann ich nicht verstehen. Doch, es ist schon so, dass die kleineren oder so, wenn die dann viele Aggressionen haben oder so, und dass sie sich dann öfters kaufen oder dass sie sofort zu dem Regal gehen, wo die Spiele stehen oder so, weil das bei denen vielleicht einfach so ein Zusammenhang ist mit den anderen Sachen, die sie noch erleben und so, dass es bei denen dazugehört. Aber es ist bei ganz vielen jedem anders, finde ich.
Wer sind jetzt genau die kleineren?
Die kleineren sind die, die die Spiele nicht spielen dürfen. Also, die im Counter-Swipe spielen und unter 16 sind und so was eben. Also, die Jünger sind als Erlaub für das Spiel.
Und meinst du, dass man sie vielleicht auch vor diesen Spielen schützen sollte? Also, im Moment muss man nicht immer nur vom Verbot reden, sondern dass man auch sagt, ist es mir einfach auch besser, wenn sie sie nicht spielen oder wie siehst du das?
Ja, natürlich müssen sie geschützt werden. Aber ja, im Prinzip können ja nur die Eltern schützen, weil die Jugendamt können ja nicht überall klingeln und gucken, was spielen sie für Spiele und ja, letzten Endes kommen die Kinder auch selber an die Spiele ran und ja, aber es gibt ihnen ganz viele Eltern, die ja nicht die Verantwortung übernehmen und so. Und das ist natürlich ganz schwierig, aber das kann man eben nicht anders lösen, als dass die Eltern da aufpassen.
Hast du eine Idee oder eine Vorstellung, warum Eltern das nicht wahrnehmen? Ich meine, ist das Ignoranz oder warum kümmern sie sich nicht darum?
Ja, also Eltern sind ja Schutzbefohlen, aber ja, wenn die es nicht wahrnehmen, dann haben die andere Probleme oder kümmern sich nicht um ihr Kind. Also beschäftigen sie sich mehr mit sich selbst und das Kind ist ihnen egal. Die haben das Kind einfach bekommen und sind nicht zur Verantwortung gewusst. Also ja, das ist bescheuert, weil da könnte das Kind auch nichts für. Aber letztendlich liegt es eben an den Eltern und die haben vielleicht ihre eigenen Sachen und meinen, dass das nicht so wichtig ist oder das läuft schon mit dem Kind oder dass sie dann sich selber was einreden, keine Ahnung.
Also auch vielleicht gar nicht wissen, was ihr Kind da spielt, meinst du?
Genau, ja, das ist auch einfach, vor seinen Eltern zu verstecken, was man spielt oder so. Also wenn man jetzt nicht die Eltern hat, die da ganz streng sind und nachgucken, was man hat, das ist nicht so schwierig. Aber die Eltern müssen einfach schon den Willen haben und vielleicht wissen auch gar nicht so viele Eltern, dass es die Gefahr gibt und denken von ihrem Kind, ja, das würde sowas eh nie machen und würde er nicht spielen und so. Weil die Eltern vielleicht einfach eine andere Einstellung haben. Also wenn die Eltern denken, ja, so eine Spiele sind ja eklig und spiele ich nicht, dann denken die automatisch, dass ihr Kinder auch nicht so was spielen würden.
Würde es vielleicht helfen, wenn diese Altersempfehlungen, also jetzt sind es ja Freigaben, und wenn es denn, also wir hatten ja in Deutschland das System, dass das eigentlich Empfehlungen waren, wenn die, sag ich mal, ein bisschen differenzierter wären als einfach nur 12, 14, 16, 18 oder so was, wenn da genauer erklärt werden würde, warum es jetzt eine bestimmte Einstufung geben würde. Also da gibt es ja das, wie heißt das, PEGI-System.
Torsten hat ja so eine wunderbare Liste gehabt, vielleicht kannst du davon nochmal was berichten.
Erzähl doch mal, wie dieses PEGI-System funktioniert. Das scheint mir, von dem weiß ich jetzt, wie viel es gelangt.
Ich wollte ganz kurz, bevor wir zum PEGI kommen, ganz kurz noch was anmerken, Daniel. Du hast gerade gesagt, dass man bei Amazon quasi mit 13 Sachen bestellen kann, die ab 18 sind, da guckt keiner.
Ab 18 nicht, ab 16 hab ich gesagt.
Okay, ich habe gerade mal versucht, was zu bestellen, was eine Altersfreigabe ist. Da sagt mir, dass Ihre Bestellung erhält einen Artikel mit einer Altersfreigabe. Die Lieferung muss vom Empfänger persönlich entgegengenommen werden. Bitte bestätigen Sie Alter und Identität. Und dann muss im Endeffekt der Postbote dann eben gucken, ob du dafür...
Was hast du dir da angeguckt, ab 18 oder ab 16?
Ich hatte gerade einen 18er.
Ich hab das mit 16 gemacht.
Dann machen wir Folgendes, dann wird jetzt Torsten kurz was erzählen zu der PEGI einstufen und ich versuche noch mal einen 16er zu kriegen.
Okay, also ein schnell eingeschrumbes Kurzreferat. Also PEGI ist sozusagen europäische Alternative zu der USK. Also USK ist eine deutsche Einrichtung, bewertet deutsche, also Spiele, die in Deutschland erscheinen, mit verpflichtenden Altersfreigaben. Und PEGI ist halt so ein System, wo man sich selbst klassifizieren kann als Produzent. Man hat da verschiedene Fragen, kann sich da einsortieren. Und dann kommt halt die entsprechende PEGI-Freigabe raus. Und die kann zum Teil halt differieren mit den USK-Freigaben. Das ist nochmal ein anderes Thema. Das ist mehr eine Empfehlung und keine verpflichtende Freigabe. Und PEGI hat noch verschiedene Symbole, die ich eigentlich ganz gut finde. Und die zeigen zum Beispiel, ob das Spiel vulgäre Sprache enthält. Verzeihung. Ob es Diskriminierung zeigt, ob es Drogenkonsum verharmlost, ob es Kinderängstigen könnte, ob es Glücksspielelemente hat, was sicherlich auf die wenigsten Spiele zutrifft, ob es Nackt- oder Sexdarstellungen enthält und ob es Gewaltdarstellungen enthält. Also die Symbole kann ich jetzt im Radio nicht nachstellen, aber die sind halt entsprechend immer zu der Bedeutung. Das heißt, ich kriege als potenzieller Käufer noch mal so eine mehr oder weniger objektive Information hinzu. Denn an sich, das wirst du ja wissen, wenn du Spiele kaufst, die Packung ist ja voller Bilder und Grafiken, aber ich kriege halt als Elternteil keine Infos, was da mein Kind wirklich zu sehen bekommt. Und diese Pegisymbole können also ein leichter Hinweis sein, was dieses Spiel enthält. Ist aber eben nicht unbedingt das deutsche System.
Ja, und dann gibt es ja wieder die Sachen, dass entweder das jemand, also jetzt muss ich ein bisschen weiter ausholen, um meine Gedanken zu begründen, also entweder kauft es dann jemand, der das kaufen darf, also das Elternteil, oder das Kind kommt da irgendwie ran. Also wenn das Kind das kauft, dann ist ja egal, was drauf steht auf der Packung, weil wenn das Kind dran kommt und schmeißt die Packung weg und spielt das Spiel. Aber ich glaube ja auch auf den Zigaretten, wo der auch vergrößert, was da drauf steht und so. Und Zigaretten werden ja dann auch von den Leuten gekauft, die sie kaufen dürfen. Und ich weiß nicht, ob das bei denen da was verändert hat, im Prinzip, also im Zusammenhang, ob das Zigaretten gefährlicher sind oder so, weil es da jetzt größer drauf steht. Aber ich finde schon das System gut, dass wenn jetzt jemand das kauft, also ein Vater, und sagt für seinen Sohn, okay, ist jetzt was anderes als bei den Zigaretten, war ein bisschen dummes Beispiel. Aber auf jeden Fall, wenn da ein Symbol drauf ist, Vulgärsprache, dass er das dann genau sieht, dass sein Kind dann sowas spielen wird, das finde ich schon ganz gut. Aber ich weiß nicht so richtig, ob das Kinder das spielen, also die es nicht spielen dürfen, ob das daran liegt, dass die Eltern einfach nicht verstehen, dass das steht ab 16 oder so. Aber ich glaube schon, dass das dann schon sowas reduzieren würde.
Also kann ich jetzt dem entnehmen, dass wenn da auf dem Spiel nach deutscher Altersfreigabe steht ab 16, dass du dann auch der Meinung bist, dass Kinder oder Jugendliche unter 16, für die vielleicht das Spiel noch nicht so geeignet ist, oder der Film?
Ja, ist immer unterschiedlich. Haben ja auch alle vor mir schon gesagt. Aber man könnte ja jetzt nicht den Unterschied machen, weil wenn jetzt einer sagt, ich bin dafür reif genug und ich darf so spielen und jemand anders verträgt sowas nicht, dann fragt der sicher, wieso darf der das spielen und ich nicht. Das ist ja bescheuert. Das kann man ja noch weniger durchsetzen als so ein gesamtes Verbot. Ja, schwierig eben. Aber deshalb finde ich die ganzen Regelungen, wie das festgelegt ist, wie das sein soll. Die Spieler sind 16, die haben 12 und die haben 18. Das finde ich richtig gut. Aber irgendwie, dass dann auch so große Versandhänder wie Amazon sich so etwas erlauben, das finde ich dann ein bisschen komisch.
Du hast übrigens Recht. Ich habe jetzt gerade versucht, Quake 4 zu bestellen. Das ist überhaupt gar kein Problem. Das steht dran bitte ab 16. Also ich habe die 16 überschritten, aber es würde mir quasi ohne Altersnachweis ausgeliefert werden. Lieber Daniel, alle anderen, die anrufen. Da wird sich Fritz in den nächsten Tagen darum kümmern. Wir rufen bei Amazon mal an und fragen, was das soll. Super. Danke für den Anruf. Freuen wir nach, die Leitungen brummen ohne Ende. Jetzt haben schon ein paar Leute Mails geschrieben oder ins Board geschrieben. Wir kommen nicht durch. Wir würden gerne mitdiskutieren. Ihr könnt sowohl online mitdiskutieren auf fritz.de im Fritz-Board oder auch bei chaosradio.ccc.de. Ich hoffe, die war richtig. Auch damit machen im Chat. 0331 70 97 110 ist die Nummer. Ich sage mal grob vorsichtig, noch halbe Stunde. Dann dürfte es wahrscheinlich wieder Luft geben, bis ihr hier mitdiskutieren könnt zum Thema. Der nächste am Telefon wartet schon ziemlich lange. Das ist auf jeden Fall Frederik aus Zeuten, 14 Jahre alt. Hallo Frederik. Danke für die Geduld.
Ja, ich wollte mal erstens was sagen zu Counter-Strike. Da gibt es ja im Internet so Videos auf MyVideo oder sowas, die man sich da angucken kann, wo bestimmte Personen da spielen. Und irgendwie, ich finde das ziemlich langweilig. Und das verstehe ich nicht, wie Leute da stundenlang dran sitzen können.
Bist du sonst ein Computerspieler?
Ja, ich spiele schon, aber jetzt nicht so ein Freak.
Was spielst du?
Na ja, also alles quer durch die Reihe.
Na komm, sag mal was.
Ähm, ja, Golfspiele halt und bisschen Ego-Shooter halt auch.
Ego-Shooter, aber nicht Counter-Strike?
Nein, Counter-Strike nicht.
Welche Shooter sind es denn dann?
So eher zweiter Weltkrieg-Shooter und so.
Wo ist da der Unterschied zu Counter-Strike? Also abgesehen vom Plot?
Ja, Counter-Strike ist halt wie schon gesagt taktisch erst mal. Aber auch dieses Spiel, was ich jetzt meine von Zweiter Weltkrieg, ist halt auch taktisch.
Was, Medal of Honor oder was?
Nee, nee, Call of Duty 2.
Call of Duty, du bist 14, darfst du eigentlich auch noch nicht spielen?
Ja, ich weiß. Ja genau, dazu wollte ich auch noch was sagen, dann gleich. Okay, dieses Call of Duty 2 ist ab 18 erstmal, falls jemand da ist, der das nicht weiß, ab wie vieler da ist. Und da ist eigentlich so, ich hatte irgendwie mal einen Gutschein bekommen und da hab ich mir mal gedacht, den löse ich da mal ein. Bin mit meinem Vater zum Mediamarkt gegangen und dann hab ich das da gesehen. Ich hab da auch schon mal eine Demo von gespielt, die kann man sich ja überall runterladen im Internet, kostenlos. Und dann hat er mir das halt geholt. Aber das ist halt auch wieder so eine Marktlücke, also nicht Marktlücke, sondern eher so eine Lücke bei dem FSK und dem ganzen Altersdreigarm und so.
Was für eine Lücke?
Naja, dass man halt die Fragen halt nicht nach, für wen das ist. Da kann man, kann der Erwachsener eigentlich kaufen, was er will. Für Personen, die 10 Jahre alt sind, da kann er Spiel ab 18 kaufen und alles Mögliche.
Achso, du meinst, dein Vater geht das an der Kasse kaufen und die fragen ihn nicht, wollen sie das spielen oder ihre Kinder?
Genau, das ist halt oft ein Problem.
Das würde ich nicht sagen. Ich denke mal, da spielt die Verantwortung der Eltern eine Rolle. Und ich glaube, Verkäufer sollte sich nicht ermächtigen, einem Elternteil, ob deinem Vater oder deiner Mutter, jetzt diese Verantwortung abzusprechen.
Ich würde das auch als Freiheit empfinden, wenn ich ein Spiel kaufe und der mich fragt, für wen ist das? Das geht denen einfach mal überhaupt nichts an. Ihm geht irgendwie an, ob ich die Altersfreigabe erfülle, ob ich also dann 18 bin oder älter. Und mehr hat ihn eigentlich schon nichts zu interessieren.
Im Zweifelsfall, also solltest du mit deinem Vater dahingehen und quasi du legst das Spiel auf den Tisch und dein Papa legt den Fuffi auf den Tisch, dann kann der Verkäufer schon mal sagen, sie wissen schon, dass das ab 18 ist. Aber ansonsten geht das glaube ich ein bisschen weiter. Dann müsste in dem Fall eher dein Vater sich mal fragen lassen, warum er dir Spiele gibt, die ab 18 zugelassen sind. Hat dein Papa mal geguckt, was das für ein Spiel ist?
Ja, das hat er sich gründlich angeguckt und dann musste ich auch noch mit ihm diskutieren und so.
Was waren die Diskussionsgründe, Punkte?
Naja, er hat halt nicht so ein gutes Verhältnis zu schießen.
Was nachvollziehbar ist.
Genau, das kann ich auch verstehen, aber im Echtleben Menschen umbringen, das ist jetzt... Da sagen die meisten immer, ich bringe ihn um und dann laufen sie auch mal. Aber irgendwie ist das bei anderen Menschen...
Nein, nein.
Also Menschen umbringen, das ist überhaupt nicht.
Nee, danke, das würde ich niemals machen.
Aber worauf habt ihr euch jetzt geeinigt? Dein Vater hat gesagt, auf Leute schießen ist Unsinn, Schmarn, Blödsinn, was auch immer er gesagt hat, und du spielst es aber trotzdem. Also müsst ihr ja einen Konsens gefunden haben.
Ja, wir haben sozusagen ausgemacht, dass es halt... Naja, ich hab ihm dann halt ein bisschen was darüber erklärt.
Was waren denn deine Argumente?
Also meine Argumente waren halt, dass man nicht wahllos irgendwelche Personen umlietet, sondern das ist halt auch, wie schon gesagt, mit Taktik auch.
Weil das ist nicht einfach nur Bam-Bam. Weil sonst ist man sofort weg.
Weil die anderen schneller Bam-Bam gemacht haben, oder?
Nee, wir waren beim Argument, was du gegenüber deinem Vater hattest.
Genau, also erstmal, dass es taktisch ist und dass es nicht wahlloses Rumgeballere ist. Und dann das zweite Argument war auch noch, weil nach einer Zeit ist irgendwie alles nicht mehr so aktuell. Und das Spiel war dann halt, weil ich das unbedingt haben wollte.
Also im Endeffekt hast du so lange gequengelt, bis er entnervt gesagt hat, mach doch.
Nein, also er hat nicht gesagt, mach doch. Dann haben wir uns halt geeinigt, dass ich dann bestimmte Arbeiten auf eine bestimmte Zeit machen muss.
Wie, ihr habt euch darauf geeinigt, dass du dieses Spiel spielen kannst und dafür musst du das Auto waschen oder so?
Oder Hause füttern?
Staubsaugen, Müll runterbringen, Katze füttern? Alter, ist nicht wahr.
Ist ja geil.
Hat dein Vater das Spiel gespielt?
Ja, er hat mir mal dabei zugeguckt.
Aber sag mal, Frederik, ist doch eigentlich total cool, wie das gelaufen ist, oder? Also soll das nicht genau so laufen? Also jetzt nicht unbedingt, dass ihr dauernd Spiele spielt, hier bei 18 sind, aber ist doch eigentlich ein ganz schöner Prozess. Er hat sich Zeit für dich genommen, ihr habt das gemeinsam diskutiert, du musst das argumentieren. Und muss jetzt regelmäßig das Auto waschen.
Naja, regelmäßig.
Das hat sich jetzt schon erledigt.
Ich meine, wärst du dir am Nachhinein lieber gewesen, er hätt's dir einfach gekauft und du hättest es gespielt? Oder fandest du es über den Weg ganz okay?
Ja, und dann wollte ich eigentlich noch was sagen. Die Zeitschriften werden ja auch überall verkauft und da achtet auch kein Verkäufer eigentlich drauf.
Du meinst, die Computer einfach gemacht und so? Entschuldigung, ich mach mal den Mikrofon auf.
Die Demos, die dann dabei gelegt sind, die sind das Problem, oder?
Da bin ich mir allerdings nicht sicher, ob die wirklich so ungeprüft auf den Markt kommen. Ich glaube, da gibt es bei den Zeitschriften inzwischen einfach verschiedene Versionen. Dass du eben dann nicht komplette Demo-Versionen hast oder eine abgespeckte Version ab 16.
Also ich kenne es von meinen Heavy-Metal-Zeitungen, die ich immer kaufe. Da steht immer drin, der Inhalt dieser Zeitschrift ist nicht jugendbeeinträchtigend. Oder der CD oder so. Das steht da explizit drauf, damit der Verkäufer sich darüber im Klaren ist, dass er da keine Dinge verkauft, für die er benannt werden kann.
Jetzt noch mal ganz kurzer Einschub bei Amazon. Zu der Amazon-Geschichte ist es also ein technisches Problem, weil man kann der Post nicht mitteilen, was sie genau prüfen sollte. Sie können nur sagen, ok, 18 oder nicht. Aber es gibt da keine Einstufungen weiter.
Die können dich ab 16 oder ab 12 prüfen. Die können nur erwachsen oder nicht erwachsen.
Ja, genau, das wurde mir gerade so schriftlich per mail berichtet.
Aber interessant, da können wir ja trotzdem noch mal nachfragen. Das ist trotzdem eine interessante These. Frederik, danke für den Anruf. Und viel Spaß bei der nächsten Diskussion mit deinem Papa. Kinder, die Leitung brummt. Wir werden wahrscheinlich heute nicht alle Leute rankriegen. Der nächste am Telefon, der schon ganz doll lange wartet, ist Jörg aus Kamin. Hallo, Jörg.
Ja, einen wunderschönen Abend.
Die erste Frage, wo ist Kamin?
Das ist nicht Kamin, das ist Kamen, Kreis Unanahe, Dortmund.
Ah, okay, also klar.
Ja, da wartet auch ein Kollege, Miro, der kommt auch später noch, der kann das vielleicht noch ein bisschen näher erklären.
Kamen, das Berg Kamen, die Ecke irgendwo.
Ja, genau.
Du bist 23.
Genau, ich bin 23. Ich bin eigentlich, ja, man hat mir fast schon all meine Argumente genommen. Ich bin ziemlich begeistert, was die Vorredner, gerade die Jüngeren bisher alles gesagt haben. Das bestätigt eigentlich auch nur meine These. Ich finde es absoluten ausgemacht, ein Quatsch, dass man über Killerspiele und so ein riesen Premorium macht. Ich denke, das wird mir, ich hoffe, es wird mir nicht böse nachher auch noch mal erwähnen, es ist wohl auch bestätigt worden, dass alle, oder dass die ganzen Amokläufer, die da halt mit in diese Argumentation reingebracht werden, dass die überdurchschnittlich schlau waren, dass sie also nicht blöd waren. Ich persönlich bin der absolut festen Überzeugung, dass das, ich sag mal, immens viel mit der Aufklärung zu tun hat. Ich selbst bin Vater von einer kleinen Tochter und natürlich mach ich mir darüber auch Gedanken. Oder auch darauf hin schon einige Male angesprochen, weil ich halt auch sehr viel mit EDV zu tun hab. Und ich denke, dass es genauso wie jetzt das bei meinem Vorredner gelaufen ist, genauso bin ich der Meinung, sollte es laufen, dass zumindest, dass man die Zeit nimmt, dass man Initiative zeigt und dass man sich auch ein bisschen damit beschäftigt. Natürlich wird man nicht alles auseinandernehmen können bis ins kleinste Detail, aber ich bin schon der Meinung, dass das Kinder und gerade die Jüngeren verstehen sollten, worum es da geht und dass das halt nicht echt ist oder so. Aber ich bin absolut nicht der Meinung, dass es Aggressivität fördert.
Thorsten hat gerade einen Einwurf.
Ja, das eben gesagt, dass die Diskussion so ein bisschen überflüssig sei oder zumindest fasse ich das mal jetzt so grob zusammen. Ich stimme dir zu, die ist auf jeden Fall viel zu aufgeregt und auch viel zu reflexartig immer. Aber kannst du dir trotzdem ein bisschen was abgewinnen? Also hältst du sie für überflüssig oder kannst du auch schon verstehen, dass Diskussionen auftauchen? In Bezug auf Killerspiele oder die sogenannten Killerspiele, Ego-Shooter oder ähnliches?
Also in Bezug auf Killerspiele kann ich es in keinster Weise verstehen. Weil ich bin mehr und mehr der Meinung, dass einfach, ich weiß jetzt leider nicht mehr, wie die Frau vorhin hieß, die angerufen hat. Antje. Antje, dass das einfach auch ein Stück weit an der Gesellschaft liegt. Also ich habe diese Diskussion nicht von Anfang an verfolgt, hier Erfurt und so. Aber ich habe eben mitbekommen, dass das von dem Typen, der da eben ausgerastet ist, mehrfach bekannt war, dass der eben mit Waffen irgendwie durch den Fett gelaufen ist oder da in irgendeinem Bunker da rumgehaust hat und so. Und da stelle ich mir dann einfach die Frage, warum kriegt man sowas mit und reagiert nicht darauf. Warum wussten die Eltern nichts davon, bzw. warum haben sie da nicht eingegriffen? Das ist für mich absolute Fahrlächtigkeit. Da gehören dann die Eltern dementsprechend zur Rechenschaft gezogen. Das würde ich mir persönlich auch nie verzeihen, wenn ich sage, meine Tochter ist jetzt 16 und kommt da mit irgendwelchen Klamotten um die Ecke. Und das hat Konsequenzen dann für sie. Also ich sag mal, dass sie dann anfängt, Leute abzuschlachten oder so. Da würde ich an mir selbst zweifeln. Da würde ich wirklich sagen, okay, da hast du was nicht mitgekriegt, warst du nicht aufmerksam genug oder sonst irgendetwas. Es ist immer sehr einfach, das dann auf so Banalitäten, die schon ewig und drei Tage da waren, also Killerspiele abzuschieben. Killerspiele waren schon immer da und auch irgendwelche Skispiele, und die kann man ja jetzt...
Und auch die Diskussion darüber, dass man sagt, die Gesellschaft ist schuld oder die Politik ist schuld, man muss sich darum kümmern und man kehrt in dem Moment weder in seinem eigenen Garten noch vor seiner eigenen Tür und fragt sich, habe ich mich jemals dafür interessiert, was meine Zwerge eigentlich in ihrem Kinderzimmer so machen, wenn die Tür zu ist.
Ganz genau.
Du hast von Miro erzählt, wir nehmen jetzt noch Miro an die Leitung und wollt ihr noch auch schnell Hallo sagen?
Wir können uns auch gerne Hallo sagen.
Hallo Miro. Ey, von Una zu Una über Babelsberg, das möchte man sich mal bitte kurz geografisch vorstellen.
Klein und dann passt das schon.
Gut Jungs, ihr könnt dann später noch miteinander euch Nettigkeiten austauschen. Danke Jörg.
Ja, kein Problem. Ich danke euch.
Miro, was hast du zuzufügen?
Jörg hat das ja richtig gut schon reingebracht. Das ist irgendwie so eine Diskussion. Das hat ja alles hier so Richtung Politiker angefangen. Da ist ja was passiert. Das Kind ist in den Brunnen gefallen und dann dachte man sich, ja, wo ist der Grund? Irgendwie, ich hab wohl schon mal so ein paar Leute kennengelernt, die so ein bisschen drauf sind. Also jetzt kein Armokläufer oder sowas.
Was meinst du mit so ein bisschen drauf?
Kannst du das präzisieren? Die, ich sag mal, die auf diese Spiele so ein bisschen komisch reagieren.
Also die das doof finden oder die es bedenklich finden. Oder die dadurch die Spiele aggressiv werden und dadurch animiert werden.
Wo ich mir immer so ein bisschen Sorgen mache, ich möchte nicht unbedingt sofort, also den ganzen Tag in deren Nähe sein. Weil das Problem ist doch, das hat doch alles immer einen Hintergrund. Zum Beispiel jetzt die Sache mit Erfurt. Der Typ wurde irgendwie, ich glaub, von den Leuten meistens gehändelt oder so, von seinen Klassenkameraden. Das hat sich dann irgendwie aufgebaut und ich glaube, das war sowieso bei jedem von den Leuten.
Also die Probleme von Steinhäusern waren nochmal umfassender. Also es ging nicht nur um Hänseleien. Hänseleien reicht noch glaube ich nicht aus.
Durch die Prüfung geflogen.
Und dann nicht mehr zugelassen worden, genau.
Und wenn dann irgendwie so rein zufällig der Vater mal wieder im Schützensverein ist, ich glaube, das war auch fast bei jedem der Fall, dass die irgendwie ziemlich leicht an die Knacken gekommen sind. Da macht sich aber natürlich keiner der Politiker Gedanken drüber so. Und irgendwo ist diese Diskussion über diese Ballerspiele recht albern. Ich meine, ich hab früher Duden gespielt, das hat mir auch nichts getan.
Na ja, pass auf, aber trotz alledem wird ja diskutiert, gerade jetzt im Moment wird wieder darüber diskutiert, der Kultusminister und auch in Bayern kommt immer wieder der Vorschlag, es müssen solche Videos verboten werden, solche Spiele müssen verboten werden und im Allgemeinen ist das alles viel zu lax. Und die Jugendlichen sind alle gefährdet. Du hast gerade angeführt, dass die gerne immer wieder an dem Punkt herangenommenen Argumente der Amokläufe in Emstetten und in Erfurt, dass die relativ wenig mit Spielen zu tun haben, dass sich keiner mit den Personen beschäftigt hat, die die Täter waren. Aber trotz alledem ist diese Diskussion ja da und deswegen diskutieren wir ja auch heute darüber, wie das jetzt mit dem ach so laxen Jugendschutz in Deutschland eigentlich ist, wie die Praxis aussieht und was man da jetzt praktisch ändern kann.
Sicher, aber man kann jetzt nicht nur die ganze Zeit über die Spiele reden. Ich denke mal, dass die Spiele nur ein Teil davon sind. Was vielleicht wichtiger ist, sind die Leute, die die Reaktion von den Leuten, wie sie das aufnehmen. Ich hab ehrlich gesagt, ganz ehrlich, ich hab kein Problem damit, wenn ein 14-jähriger Counter-Strike spielt. Hab ich kein Problem mit. Nur wenn diese Person, ich sag mal ganz dreist, wenn diese Person labil ist, so was nicht verkraften kann. Oder hinterher merkt, verdammt, die Leute haben mich geärgert. Mein Vater hat auch eine Knarre, dann mach ich das mal schon mal weg. Meine Probleme, das ist das Schlimme.
Aber meinst du denn, man kann tatsächlich abschätzen, welche langfristigen Auswirkungen sowas auf Jugendliche auch hat, so einen Einfluss von Spielen. Das heißt, wenn du es einfach gewohnt bist, jeden Tag zwei Stunden auf Menschen zu schießen, egal ob es jetzt Pixel-Menschen sind, dass es einfach so diese Abstumpfungseffekte da ist. Glaubst du nicht, dass es nicht auch eine Rolle spielen könnte?
Ja, das kommt halt wieder auf diese Person an. Ich meine, ich kann bestimmt auch zwei Stunden jeden Tag spielen, wenn ich die Zeit hätte und mir wird das auch nicht wirklich was tun. Es ist gut, es könnte unter Umständen sein, es kommt vielleicht darauf an, mit was für einem Alter man anfängt. Weil, wenn man ja irgendwie jünger ist, na, ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Ich glaube, dass es viel einfacher ist. Man kann sich auch nicht, anstatt zu sagen, es ist für Jugendliche zugänglich oder nicht, kann man auch nicht sagen, das ist mit 11, 12, 13 oder 14. Da gibt es eine Grenze, wo ein Schalter umgelegt wird, Leute können so etwas verkraften. Viel eher müssen sich die Leute, die im direkten Umfeld sind, Gedanken machen, was da um sie herum passiert. Und nicht nur sagen, da muss sich der Lehrer darum kümmern, wenn die Eltern es sagen. Oder die Lehrer sagen, ich habe andere Sachen zu tun, dann müssen sich die Eltern darum kümmern. Wenn Lehrer und Eltern es nicht schaffen, sagen sie beide, da muss sich der Staat darum kümmern. Der Ball wird immer von einer Hälfte in die andere gespielt und keiner ist wirklich bereit, dazu Verantwortung zu übernehmen. Ich glaube, da sind wir an dem Punkt, über den wir heute noch diskutieren werden. Annette hat noch einen Einruf und dann sind wir schon über die Nachrichten, es gibt Ärger.
Ich glaube auch, dass der Jugendmedienschutz, wie er momentan in Deutschland existiert, nicht darauf ausgerichtet ist, Kinder und Jugendliche davor zu schützen oder zu bewahren, Amok zu laufen, sondern ganz klar eigentlich dafür da ist, sie vor bestimmten Inhalten zu schützen. Wie zum Beispiel Sechsjährige vor zu krasser Gewalt.
Sechsjährige, klar.
Das nehme ich auch so, ist auch so vernünftig. Aber hier allein dieser Begriff Ballerspiele, das ist einfach nur albern.
Da gebe ich dir vollkommen recht.
Das wurde, glaube ich, von euch auch mal ziemlich gut beschrieben. Das ist einfach nur eine Diskussion, die von Politikern angefangen wurde und wo Berater waren, die den Leuten mal in zwei Minuten erklärt haben, worum es da geht. Und die haben einfach keine Ahnung.
Danke für den Anruf, Miro. Hui, die Leitungen sind voll. Wir haben noch eine Menge zu diskutieren. Philipps noch dran, Sven, Jan, Erik, Axel ist auch noch da. Wir wollen auch noch mit Herrn Brüning reden. Herr Brüning ist... Frank, der hat dir eine Mail geschrieben. Der ist Wissenschaftler. Pass auf, wir erklären einfach Nachrichten. Bleiben Sie dran, Herr Brüning.
Wie hieß der erste deutsche Fernsehsender? Ist es so, ja?
Ja.
Ich glaube auch, der zweite? Nennen wir mal 5 dritte Programme.
5 dritte, WDR, RBB und natürlich noch Bayern 3.
Ja, das sind 3?
9 von 7 Deutschen können nicht richtig zählen. Sind aber trotzdem gern dabei. Das Fritz-Kneipen-Quiz. Jede Woche, Donnerstag, woanders. Morgen Abend im Oranke am See. Berlin Hohenschönhausen. Aber immer ab 22 Uhr. Mit Tommy Wosch. Michi Balzer.
Ich hab mich immer davon aus, oder?
Und Fritz-Kneipen-Quiz-Master Thomas Vogel. Das Fritz-Kneipen-Quiz.
Und das hört man.
Fünf nach halb zwölf.
Mit Grisha Zedelke. Der bisherige britische Premierminister Blair ist zum neuen Sondergesandten des Neust Quartetts anhand worden. Das gab die UNO in New York bekannt. In seiner neuen Funktion soll Blair die Friedensbemühungen zwischen Israelis und Palästinensern wiederbeleben. Vorrangig ist dabei die Suche nach einer Zwei-Staaten-Lösung. Blair hatte das Amt des Regierungschefs am Nachmittag nach 10 Jahren aufgegeben. Anschließend wurde sein Nachfolger Gordon Brown mit der Regierungsbildung beauftragt. Im Radsport gibt es offenbar einen neuen Dopingfall. Matthias Kessler, langjähriger Helfer von Jan Ulrich und Andreas Klöden wurde im April positiv auf Testosteron getestet. Das gab sein Rennstall Astana bekannt. Kessler wurde zunächst bis zum Ergebnis der B-Probe suspendiert. Er war fest für die am 7. Juli beginnende Tour de France eingeplant. Die Bundesregierung hatte ein neues Förderprogramm für Langzeitarbeitslose beschlossen. Arbeitsminister Müntefering stellte im Kabinett einen sogenannten Kommunal-Kombilohn vor. Der Bund will danach Anfang 2008 für einen Zeitraum von drei Jahren die Hälfte des Lohns übernehmen, wenn Kommunen oder Wohlfahrtsverbände Langzeitarbeitslose für bestimmte Tätigkeiten zusätzlich anstellen. Das Neuförderprogramm soll für alle Regionen gelten, in denen die Arbeitslosenquote mehr als 15 Prozent beträgt. Bahnchef Medon bleibt bis 2011 im Amt. Der Aufsichtsrat des Unternehmens teilte nach einer Sitzung mit, dass der Vertrag des 64-Jährigen um drei Jahre verlängert werde. Damit kann Medon die geplante Privatisierung der Bahn weiter vorantreiben. Der Bundestag hat im November grundsätzlich entschieden, das letzte große Staatsunternehmen in Deutschland bis 2009 in Teilen an die Börse zu bringen. In der Nacht wird der Wind weniger und der Regen lässt nach. Es kühlt ab auf 12 bis 9 Grad. Am Tag bleibt es wechselhaft bei 17 bis 19 Grad. Der Verkehr fritzt an. 19 Wittstockdosse Richtung Rostock zwischen dem Dreieck Wittstockdoss und Waren. Eine Müröz ist ein Schwertransport unterwegs, der nicht überholt werden kann. Und dann immer noch die A10, nördlicher Wiener Ring, Hafenland Richtung Schwarnenbeck. Zwischen Mühlenbeck und dem Dreieck Pankow besteht Gefahr durch einen defekten LKW. Der rechte Fahrstreifen ist gesperrt. Und wir haben recherchiert, der ist nicht vom ADAC dort abgestellt worden.
Wartet.
Der wartet.
Ich hab jetzt auf deine gute Fahrt gewartet.
Ja, gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 2, dann Fritz im Cottbus.
Und wir sehen uns dann bald wieder. Jugendschutz ist das Thema im Chaos Radio Teil 125 auf Fritz, letzter Mittwoch im Monat. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz, schönen guten Abend. Frank, Annett und Thorsten vom Chaos Computer Club sind auch hier. Wir haben jetzt fast anderthalb Stunden über Computerspiele geredet. Es gab bei uns auf dem Fritz Board, weil die Leitungen sind wirklich extrem voll und nicht alle kommen durch. Das tut uns zwar leid, aber ihr könnt gerne auf dem Fritz Board oder beim Chaos Radio im Chat weitermachen, mitdiskutieren. Gab es den durchaus berechtigten Einwurf, jetzt haben ganz viele Leute gesagt, es gibt schon einen Unterschied zwischen taktischen Spielen wie Counterstrike und bloßem Abschießen von Leuten. Und der Einwurf, der durchaus diskussionswürdig ist, war, wo ist da der Unterschied, ob es jetzt taktisch ist oder nicht. Es geht darum, irgendwie Leute kalt zu machen, Pixel hin oder her. Es ist eine Gewaltdarstellung, eine Gewaltverherrlichung und eine Art und Weise, die natürlich vom Spieler selbst ausgeht, die er selbst auslöst. Und da sollte man das nicht kleiner reden, als es eigentlich ist. Diskutiert damit 0331 70 97 110. Der nächste am Telefon ist Christoph aus Siegen. Guten Abend, Christoph. Du kommst quasi von der anderen Seite die Straße lang. Du bist Student auf Lehramt und beschäftigst dich von Berufswegen mit dem Thema.
Ja, was heißt von Berufswegen? Also es hat sich irgendwann die Möglichkeit ergeben, dass ich meine Abschlussarbeit, wir müssen so eine Startsarbeit schreiben, neben den ganzen Prüfungen, Examen, dass ich diese Arbeit über Computerspiele auch schreiben kann. Ja, und also eigentlich habe ich die mehr über Computerspielen zu Kindern und Jugendliteratur geschrieben, also Harry Potter, TKKG und so was.
Also Computerspiele, die sich quasi mit solchen Büchern beschäftigen.
Genau, oder die halt in diesem Themenumfeld irgendwie angesiedelt sind. Ich habe mich natürlich auch in dieser Kielerspieldebatte dann erstmal im Rahmen meiner Startsabit auseinandergesetzt und dann wurde das nachher zu so einem Hobby, dass ich mich echt gefragt habe, was geht da ab bei den Leuten? Also ich habe irgendwie zuerst gedacht, gut, das sind die Politiker, die schießen irgendwelche Sachen raus, wie sie das immer machen und habe aber dann angefangen, das kann ja nicht alles sein. Ich habe dann mit Lehrern gesprochen, mit Pädagogieprofessoren, mit Psychologieprofessoren, mit allen möglichen Leuten, um mal dahinter zu kommen, warum die Leute jetzt alle nach diesem Verbot schreien.
Und du hast auch mit Politikern gesprochen?
Ja, genau.
Und?
Ja, gut, was soll ich sagen. Also die erwartbaren Reaktionen. Je weiter links man irgendwie im politischen Farbespektrum kommt, desto verneiner werden die Antworten, was das Verbot angeht. Und je weiter rechts oder mittig man sich bewegt, desto mehr wird nach diesem Verbot gejammert.
Und wie begründen die Leute dieses Verbot? Warum sind sie davon überzeugt, dass das wirklich sinnvoll ist?
Das geht so von ganz allen Seiten. Wenn wir das Verbot haben, gibt es keine Armhaukläufe mehr. Da brauchen wir gar nicht so mal reden über so eine Argumentation. Bis zu so Sachen, wir brauchen das unbedingt, weil der bisherige Jugendlichenschutz nicht funktioniert. Und die Leute sind völlig immun. Ich habe da wirklich teilweise über mehrere Stunden mit den Leuten diskutiert und denen klar gemacht, nicht der Jugendschutz ist das Problem, sondern wie wir den zurzeit angehen ist das Problem. Und wie die Leute vielleicht mitfehlen, dass Lehrer, Eltern, dass sie keine Medienkompetenz haben.
Wie kann das denn...
Also Medienkompetenz finde ich ist genau das richtige Schlagwort. Also dass man halt gerade an Schulen und Erziehungs- und Bildungseinrichtungen mehr in Richtung Sozialkompetenz, Lesekompetenz und Medienkompetenz unterrichten oder lehren sollte.
Ich glaube der Ansatz von Christoph klang eben so ein bisschen anders als müssten erstmal die Lehrer auch Medienkompetenz sein.
Ohne Frage.
Also gut, also das ist halt die Sache. Wenn ich Güte unterrichten will, muss ich Güte kennen. Ich muss zumindest so was damit auskennen, dass ich es glaubhaft unterrichten kann. Und wenn ich mich so in meinem Umfeld umgucke, ich möchte nicht über meine ganzen Kommilitonen irgendwie rumrenten und die irgendwie alle über einen Kamm scheren. Aber ich sehe da zwei Arten von Leuten. Die einen mögen Killerspiele, die anderen mögen sie nicht und alle zusammen haben eigentlich keine differenziertere Meinung darüber hinaus. Viele haben die Spiele gar nicht gespielt. Und viele wollen sich auch überhaupt nicht damit beschäftigen, selbst wenn man denen sagt, eure Schüler spielen das nachher, ihr müsst das kennen, einfach um zu wissen, wie wir darauf reagieren müssen. Das wird dann einfach abgewiegelt. Nee, nee, das ist ja alles schlecht und die Politiker machen das verboten, dann ist für uns die Sache gegessen.
Aber was glaubst du denn, was ist denn das Ziel davon, wenn diese Medienkompetenz erst mal da ist, dass die Jugendlichen die Spiele nicht mehr spielen, weil sie sie denn blöd finden, aus welchen Gründen? Oder dass sie die zwar spielen, aber ich sag mal, ja, verstehen, reflektieren, Abstand davon gewinnen. So. Also was ist denn da das Ziel davon, wenn sie denn medienkompetenter werden?
Also ich würde mir, ja anders. Wir haben bei vielen anderen Sachen, können wir den Schülern irgendwelche Entscheidungskompetenzen mit an die Hand geben. Wir können ihnen erklären, wie man urteilt, ob etwas gut oder etwas schlecht für einen ist. Und das passt viel sicher. Wir wissen zum Beispiel von unserem Biologieunterricht her, dass sie was gegen Eis tun müssen. Und dass irgendwie Rechtsextremismus auch sehr schlecht ist. Aber bei dieser Medienkompetenzgeschichte würde es eigentlich erstmal darum gehen, den Schülern überhaupt mal klar zu machen, die Dinger sind nicht einfach nur irgendwas für die Freizeit, sondern die kann man auch bewerten. Also ich würde gar nicht so weit gehen und sagen wollen, dass sie dann alle aufhören zu spielen, bloß weil wir denen erklärt haben, dass das Mist ist. Darüber will ich ja gar nicht hinaus. Aber um das nochmal von der anderen Seite anzugehen, ein großes Problem ist, dass man meistens, wenn man über dieses Killerspielverbot spricht, man hat diese Spiele im Kopf. Und wenn ich mit den Leuten gesprochen habe, haben die mir gesagt, ja, man hat mir gezeigt, wie da Menschen abgeschlachtet werden. Und ich hab dann gefragt, hatten sie das denn auch mal gespielt? Ja nee, mir hat das ja gereicht, wie man das gesehen hat, wie die da abgeschlachtet wurden. Und es ist einfach ein ganz krasser Unterschied bei Computerspielen, ob man teilnimmt, ob man spielt oder ob man nicht spielt. Denn was man da wahrnimmt, wenn man nicht spielt, ist ein Gesamtbild. Und wenn man da spielt, ist man da ganz anders involviert. Und dann tosiert man sich vielleicht gar nicht für das Toten, sondern irgendwie für das Spielen an sich, was man da gerade an Bewegung ausführt.
Darüber gibt es auch durchaus psychologische und wissenschaftliche Studien. Das war in der letzten Sendung zum Thema quasi auch fast eine halbe Stunde lang ein Gesprächswert, dass ein Psychologe das quasi per Hirnstrom und per Analyse untersucht hat, was passiert, wenn man das selber spielt, welche Reflexe und Reaktionen angesprochen werden und wie das aussieht, wenn man nur zuguckt. Also quasi, Schrägstrich, das im Fernsehen in einem Beitrag sieht und dann denkt, das ist die Wirklichkeit. Das sind zwei unterschiedliche Baustellen, hast du recht.
Jaja, und was das andere ist, ich hab mich dann auch wirklich mit einem Psychologieprofessor mal hingesetzt und gefragt. Also ich hab mir diese Studie besorgt, die als Grundlage genommen haben, um das Kielerspielverbot im Koalitionsvertrag zu verankern. Und also das ist peinlich. Das ist wirklich peinlich und das sage nicht ich, sondern das hat der Psychologieprofessor. Ich kann da jetzt mal kurz ein bisschen über abziehen. Da wird ein Datenbestand genommen von angloamerikanischen Jugendlichen im Alter von 14 bis 17 Jahren, von 1950 bis 1975 über das Fernsehverhalten von diesen jungen Menschen und erklärt, warum wir jetzt ein Kielerspielverbot brauchen. Das ist kein Witz.
Weißt du, wer dahinter steckt, Christoph?
Ha, Lukasch, der ist, glaube ich, das ist jetzt Universität Regensburg, da müsste ich gerade selber nochmal googeln.
Lukasch hat so eine undifferenzierte Studie veröffentlicht?
Kennst du, Entschuldigung, du guckst so, wissen kennst du den, kannst du was dazu sagen?
Nee, das wäre jetzt wieder gefährliches Halbwissen, aber Lukasch wäre mir noch nicht auffällig geworden in dem Bereich. Deswegen bin ich verwundert.
Also vor allem in Unionsnähe, was da an Papieren irgendwie erstellt wird, hat Lukasch auffällig häufig irgendwie eine Studie dazu gemacht. Also die Sache ist, die Meinpsychologie-Prof hat da wieder gesagt, irgendwie das ist gut noch, das ist schlecht. Der hat einfach gesagt, wer momentan behauptet, da gibt es irgendwie einen Zusammenhang, der lübt ganz einfach, weil die Forschung ist noch nicht so weit.
Es gibt keine empirischen Evidenzen, keine Zuhörungen. Es gibt noch keine Studie, die überzeugend gewesen wäre. Genau.
Selbst wenn die wollen würden, sie könnten momentan noch nichts sagen. Und das ist jetzt ein Problem, das müssten die Politiker ganz alleine aussitzen, wie sie dieses gesellschaftliche Problem lösen. Menschen, die an den Rand der Gesellschaft gedrängt wurden, die ins Soziale ausgedrängt wurden, die über Jahre hinweg keiner ernst oder überhaupt nur wahrgenommen hat, die müssen jetzt irgendwie entweder in die Gesellschaft zurückgeholt werden oder sonst irgendwie muss versucht werden, mit diesem Umstand jetzt klarzukommen.
Du hast ja selber eben schon einen ganz guten Anspruch auch entworfen, dass jemand, der mit Jugendlichen oder Kindern zu tun hat, selber auch die Erfahrung vorweisen muss, eben zum Beispiel als Lehramtskandidat oder später als Lehrer. Wie sehen deine Erfahrungen aus und zwar auch unabhängig von Spielen? Also bist du auch fit im Bereich Musik und Filme? Bist du auch auf dem Level der Jugendlichen? Kannst du mit denen auf einer Augenhöhe diskutieren und reden?
Das weiß ich gar nicht. Das müsste man, glaube ich, mal auf bestimmte Gruppen von Schülern loslassen. Also mein Musikgeschmack ist gänzlich an der heutigen Jugend vorbei, schätze ich einfach mal. Die Frage ist nicht, ob ich irgendwie das höre, was die Jugendlichen hören. Das glaube ich einfach nicht. Aber ich muss mich darauf einlassen können.
Also du wirst bereit, dich auch mal mit Bushido oder Sido auseinanderzusetzen, wenn das Thema wird.
Wobei Bushido und Sido natürlich ganz schön 2004 ist, wa?
Wenn ich von vornherein sage, ich kenne einige solche Leute in meinem Kommunitorenumfeld, die sagen, ich will mit diesen Spielen nichts zu tun haben, dann hab ich denen gesagt, ihr habt ein Problem, wenn eure Schüler das machen. Ihr könnt nicht einfach sagen, das ist schlecht, wenn ihr es nicht kennt. Ihr könnt es nicht. Das könnt ihr auch nicht bei Goethe machen.
Aber was sagst du denn möglicherweise zu einem Abstumpfungseffekt, der dich durch diese Computerspiele ergibt oder auch insgesamt durch Mediennutzung, wo jetzt Inhalte gezeigt werden, die jetzt auch geregelt werden sollen oder geregelt werden derzeit. Also es ist ja auch schwierig, immer nur von diesen Extremfällen, von irgendwelchen Armokläufen zu reden, sondern es findet ja insgesamt auch eine Wirkung von den Medien auf Jugendliche statt. Und glaubst du denn, dass das auch völlig abwegig ist oder würdest du dem schon zustimmen, dass es da eine gewisse Wirkung gibt auf Jugendliche?
Also, wenn man eine bestimmte Sache sehr häufig macht, dann verliert sie womöglich in Reiz und man wird abgestumpft ihr gegenüber. Und wenn ich relativ häufig sehr gewalttätige Computerspiele konsumiere, dann werde ich wahrscheinlich gegenüber dieser Form, also dieses Mitspielens von digitaler Gewalt unter Umständen, ich kann das nicht belegen, ich habe auch bisher keine empirischen Beweise dafür gefunden, dann werde ich vielleicht abgestumpft. Das ist aber nur gegen diese Form.
Im Zweifelsfall gibt es dann irgendwann zu dem Spiel ein Update und die Grafik ist besser, man kann sich daran wieder festbeißen.
Ja, die Grafik nicht, aber vielleicht ist irgendwann, kommen die doch mal auf die Idee, mal ein besseres Gameplay zu machen oder irgendwie mal da was anderes zu machen und dann gewinnt dieses Medium wieder an Reiz.
Aber sagen wir, vielleicht nehmen wir auch mal Filme mit dazu. Oder generell, was im Netz an Medien zu sehen ist. Also hauptsächlich Fotos, Videos, Filme. Da werden ja auch Sachen gezeigt, sei es ob Frauen geschlagen werden oder was auch immer. Ja, wie denkst du das? Gibt es da einen Grund, das zu regulieren oder?
Ja, gut, wir haben ja schon einen Jugendschutz, einen sehr harten, eigentlich den strengsten der selbst. Und an dem hat es bisher auch nicht gemangelt, an den Jugendschutzgesetzen hat es ja bisher nicht gemangelt, an der Umsetzung hat es tatsächlich gemangelt. Also es gibt Filme, die ich meinen Kindern nicht ohne Begleitung zeigen möchte, es gibt Filme, die ich meinen Kindern am liebsten, wenn ich jetzt welche hätte, oder meinen Schülern auch nachher bis zu einem gewissen Alter überhaupt nicht zeigen möchte. Es gibt auch Computerspiele, die ich einfach bei meinen Schülern nicht sehen möchte am liebsten, aber genauso gibt es auch Bücher. Das ist aber jetzt die Frage, ob sie das einfach alles konsumieren können, wie sie es wollen. Welche Reife ich ihnen schon anerkenne. Also diese Sachen mit den Altersangaben ist eine witzige Hilfe, aber mehr auch nicht. Also ich kenne durchaus 12-Jährige, die bereit sind, Medien ab 18 zu konsumieren. Und ich kenne durchaus 18-Jährige, denen man sie immer noch nicht in die Hand geben sollte.
Würde denn dieses differenzierte System wie das PEGI-System, würde das deiner Meinung nach was bringen? Dass also die Eltern schon eher begreifen und das nicht nur als so eine Formalien sehen.
Dass auf den Artikeln quasi kleine so Piktogramme drauf sind, auf denen drauf steht, erhält Gewalt, enthält Drogen, enthält Nacktheit, so was, dass man genauer weiß, worum es geht.
Ich habe mich da jetzt noch ehrlich gesagt nicht so mit auseinandergesetzt, aber ich würde mir so eine Plakette wünschen, wie enthält die Notwendigkeit der Partizipation der Eltern.
Das versteht ja wieder keiner.
Ja klar, das versteht keiner. Gut, das hätte natürlich einen Vorteil, wenn ich es möglichst kompliziert mache mit vielen Piktogrammen, die sich zwangsläufig damit auseinandersetzen müssen. Das ist vielleicht noch die Sache. Ich würde mir wünschen, dass es anders verankert ist. Wir haben alle mal mitgekriegt, dass wir später Kinder haben, zu einem gewissen Zeitpunkt die aufklären müssen. Wir kennen das als dieses unangenehme Eltern-Kind-Gespräch, was irgendwann auf uns zukommt. Ich würde mir wünschen, dass sie irgendwie in unserem Alltag das nachher so verwurzelt ist, dass wir automatisch wissen, wenn wir später mal Kinder haben, dann müssen wir ihnen erklären, wie man mit Medien umgeht. Und zwar nicht, wir müssen ihnen alle Medien verbieten, sondern wir müssen ihnen erklären, wie man damit umgeht.
Um deine sehr interessanten Ausführungen kurz zusammenzufassen, man muss es nicht lieben, aber man muss sich damit beschäftigen, um sich ein Urteil erlauben zu dürfen. Blumen auf Fritz, Chaos Radio Teil 125. Wir sind wirklich jetzt eine ganze Weile auf Computerspielen rumgeritten. Es geht eigentlich um den Jugendschutz in Deutschland. Wir waren bei der praktischen Umsetzung. Wie funktioniert es, was habt ihr schon erlebt? Wir haben ganz viele Anrufer gehabt, die gesagt haben, ich bin 12, kann problemlos Dinge, die es ab 18 freigegeben sind, kaufen. Ich kann mir bei Online-Händlern Dinge kaufen, die ab 16 sind. Da gibt es nicht mal eine Frage, ob ich schon 16 wäre. Und in dem Zusammenhang natürlich dann die Geschichte der geforderten noch schärferen Verbote von solchen jugendgefährdenden Gewaltspielen und Gewaltdarstellungen, ob das überhaupt was bringt, wenn sie im Endeffekt in einer praktischen Umsetzung nicht funktionieren. Und wenn sich Eltern und Lehrer und große Geschwister, Onkel, Tanten, wer auch immer, Verkäufer, Videotheksbesitzer, Postboten nicht die Mühe machen, mal drauf zu gucken, was sie da eigentlich an wen ausliefern. Darüber diskutieren wir mit euch. 0331 70 97 110. Der nächste am Telefon ist Sven aus Lichtenberg. Hallo Sven, grüß dich.
Einen wunderschönen guten Abend.
Guten Abend, musste ich ein bisschen warten, aber hier brennt heute echt der Baum.
Ich bin ja überhaupt erst mal froh, dass ich überhaupt durchgekommen bin.
Alles klar.
Das ist ja schon seit zwei Wochen das erste Mal, dass ich überhaupt durchgekommen bin.
Mensch, Sven, komm rein, ich freu mich, dass du da bist.
Ich hab sonst wie mal Batterien gewechselt. Also erst mal Punkt Nummer eins. Ich spiel dieses Spiel schon seitdem es draußen ist.
Welches Spiel?
Counter-Strike. Nicht nur solche Spiele. Also ich bin bei sowas sehr bewandert mit solchen Spielen. Nun muss man aber abwägen, kann der Mensch unterscheiden, ist das real oder ist das nicht real? Wenn die Eltern es versäumen, einem Kind beizubringen, das was im Fernsehen läuft, das was auf dem Rechner läuft, ist nicht real, bringt es auch nichts, wenn man das verbietet. Denn es heißt ja nicht umsonst Wide Wide Web. Man kann alles kriegen im Internet. Und wenn sie es verbieten, dann gibt es immer in Amerika die amerikanische Web, dann wird das eben gedownloadet. Das ist doch scheißegal, das interessiert kein Mensch. Es wird auch nicht kontrolliert. Es ist so wie man es sagt. Wide Wide Web, man kriegt alles.
Okay, wie sollte man damit umgehen?
Wie sollte man damit umgehen? Ich sage mal ganz ehrlich, es hört sich jetzt hart an, aber vielleicht wäre es die einfache Variante. Man sollte Kindern, die vielleicht eventuell noch sehr jugendlich erscheinen, vielleicht aber geistig noch nicht so weit sind, eventuell komplett das Computerspielen verbieten. Damit umgeht man das Problem der Kontrolle.
Hey Sven, Entschuldigung, Hand aufs Herz. Wenn du jetzt Leuten sagst, ihr dürft nicht Super Mario spielen, die lachen sich doch kaputt. Und im Zweifelsfall gehen sie zum Kumpel oder zum Nachbarn nebenan und zocken da. Das ist nicht der Weg.
Ich finde das eine Dreißigkeit zu sagen, wir verbieten das Spiel komplett. Damit nimmt man meine Wenigkeit, ich bin 23, die Möglichkeit. Ich bin volljährig, ich hab das Recht, mir so ein Spiel zu kaufen. Ich habe die geistige Weite, um zu sagen, ich unterscheide das. Ich kann das spielen. Aber man entzieht mir ja die Möglichkeit, das Spiel spielen zu können, weil man es einfach komplett verbietet. Man beschneidet mich in meiner Freiheit.
Damit sind wir wieder beim Thema Jugendschutz und genau da, wo wir eigentlich hinwollten. Besonders bestimmte Spiele sind ab 18 freigegeben und nicht für Leute zugänglich zu machen, die unter 18 Jahre alt sind. Sie kriegen sie trotzdem, du hast eben gesagt, im Netz.
Richtig, da müsste man irgendwie mehr Kontrolle. Aber das kann man eben nicht. Ich hab da mal einen Bericht gelesen, das ist schon ein Weilchen her, dass ich glaube, das Internet mal aufgebaut worden ist, um bestimmte Datenaustausch zu produzieren von bestimmten Firmen. Und das Ganze hier außer Kontrolle geraten ist. Man hätte, so wie die Amis das jetzt eigentlich wollten...
Das klingt ein bisschen nach einer Verschwörungstheorie. Warte mal, ich frag mal kurz beim Chaos Computer Club nach, ob das bis hierhin sachlich richtig ist. Internet ist aufgebaut worden zum Datenaustauschen, geriet irgendwann außer Kontrolle.
Na ja, außer Kontrolle ist es nicht wirklich. Ich meine, die Firmen haben es jetzt unter Kontrolle. Also ich meine, es gibt ja auch immer in Deutschland, es gab ja auch nach Emstetten auch Widerrufe, das Internet, klar, es wurde schon quasi als Quelle ausgemacht für diese Spiele, wo diese Spiele herkommen. Und deswegen hat man gesagt, okay, den machen wir halt, zensieren wir, filtern wir halt das Internet, kein Problem, zack, da ein paar Filter bei den Service-Providern, an den Knotenpunkten und dann ziehen wir den ganzen Kram aus dem Netz raus. Ist natürlich in der Praxis nicht ganz so einfach, aber das wäre natürlich die Extremvariante, das wäre dann das Modell China, was wir denn hätten. Das wäre halt einfach, bestimmte Sachen versuchen, aus dem Internet zu sperren und es dann auch konsequent durchsetzen. Also entweder macht man halt Zensur ganz oder gar nicht.
Ja, deswegen sag ich ja, es wäre der einfache Weg. Wenn sie schon sagen, wir verbieten die Spiele, dann müssten sie auch das durchführen.
Na Moment Sven, ich glaube, gleich ist es anders dran, aber ich glaube du machst das dir an dem Moment aus deiner egoistischen Perspektive als Soccer ein bisschen einfach, wenn du sagst, ich trau mir dazu, alle anderen dürfen nicht. Ich glaube, das führt in eine Sackgasse.
Genau auf den Schuh wollte ich auch gerade. Auf der einen Seite beschwerst du dich so ein bisschen darüber, dass du vielleicht in deinen persönlichen Rechten beschnitten wirst, wenn du bestimmte Spiele oder Filme nicht zugänglich hast. Und gleichzeitig bist du aber der Meinung, dass andere, die eventuell vielleicht nicht deine geistige Reife haben, das komplett verbieten. Zu verbieten, also ist dann nicht vielleicht eher Jugendmedienschutz, wie er irgendwie versucht wird zu praktizieren, ein viel besserer Ansatz, dass man irgendwie sagt, ab einem bestimmten Alter hat man irgendwie eine bestimmte geistige Reife, um bestimmte Sachen zu verstehen oder nicht. Ob das natürlich bestimmt bei verschiedenen Leuten differenziert nochmal zu sehen ist, ist eine andere Sache.
Wär es auch derjenige, der sozusagen einschätzt, der 12-jährige kann Spiele ab 16 zocken oder einen Film ab 16 sehen und der andere nicht? Das ist eine lange Diskussion, Sven. Wir werden die mit vielen Leuten heute noch weiterführen, aber deine Anregungen werden auf jeden Fall in die Diskussion mit eingehen.
Ja, das ist richtig. Ich sag mal so, man kann nicht beurteilen, der Mensch ist geistig nicht auf der Höhe. Das ist richtig. Ich muss dazu mal sagen, ich hab mir das ja auch mit diesem Armoklauf angeguckt und ich muss dazu sagen, ich bin auch Opfer eines Mobbings in der Schule. Es ist ja nicht so, dass das nur das Spiel ist. Das ist absolut falsch, war ich ganz ehrlich. Es hat mit dem Umfeld der Person zu tun. Wie wird eine Person behandelt, ja? Und das ist eben der Ausschlag. Nicht das Spiel selber, nicht der Film selber. Weil ich denke mal, dass man sich das nicht als Vor- als wie sagt man, sagen kann, das ist jetzt da passiert, so handle ich. Das funktioniert nicht. So doof kann kein Mensch sein. Sondern es hat immer einen anderen Ausschlag. Und deswegen, die Biokraten da oben machen es sich sehr einfach. Sie schlagen sozusagen, denken, sie schlagen zwei Fliegen mit einer Klappe.
Und auf der anderen Seite müssten sich eigentlich die Leute, die direkt davon betroffen sind, nämlich deine Eltern, deine Lehrer, deine Freunde, wer auch immer. Die Lehrer vor allen Dingen. Der Lehrer würde jetzt wieder sagen, Alter, ich hab Unterrichtsvorbereitungen, kann mich auch nicht noch darum kümmern, was der Sven im Privaten macht. Da müssen sich deine Eltern drum kümmern, da müssen sich deine Kumpels auch ein bisschen drum kümmern und sagen, Alter, was ist mit dir los?
Das meine ich ja nicht.
Da sollte sich schon jeder an die eigene Nase fassen.
Das meine ich ja nicht. Aber wenn man zum Beispiel als Schüler kommt und sagt, Herr Direktor, ich habe Probleme, ich werde je mobbt, ich werde fertiggemacht. Irgendwann bist du geistig so abwesen und sagst, es ist dir scheißegal. Und da hilft dir keiner, weil sie versuchen es alle unter einem Teppich zu kehren.
Genau, da sind wir an dem Punkt und da sollten sich alle, die es versuchen, unter einen Teppich zu kehren, jeder Einzelne bitte an seine Nase fassen und sich überlegen, welche Verantwortung er da gegenüber seinen Kumpels hat. Sven, pass auf, wir haben einen Haufen Anrufer. Deswegen will ich dich jetzt aus der Leitung kicken.
Ich will auch nicht weiter. Ich bedanke mich, wünsche euch noch einen schönen Abend.
Vom selben Haus rein. 0331 70 97 110. Wir reden über die Wirksamkeit von Jugendschutz in Deutschland, wie er momentan funktioniert, wie ihr ihn erlebt habt und was man machen kann, damit er wirksam oder praktikabel ist, vielleicht eher ein schöneres Wort als wirksam, umzusetzen ist, damit das, was beabsichtigt wird, nämlich Jugendliche bei der Mediennutzung, ein bisschen vor Dingen zu schützen, die sie nicht unbedingt sehen sollten, damit es auch funktioniert.
Und vor allem würde uns interessieren, wenn ihr Eltern seid, ruft auch mal an. Uns interessiert mal, wie würdet ihr mit euren Kindern umgehen, wie geht ihr mit euren Kindern damit um? Gerade wenn ihr also Eltern seid, ruft auch jetzt mal bitte an.
Aber erstmal sagt der Elektriker hier die Zeit.
Fritz.
Chaos Radio Teil 125 mit Frank Anett und Thorsten vom Chaos Computer Club. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Herzlich willkommen. Die Leitungen sind immer noch extrem voll. Ihr könnt auch gerne unter fritz.de im Fritzboard oder unter chaosradio.ccc.de euch in den Chaos Radio Chat einloggen und da auch mitdiskutieren. Eure Meinungen sind alle willkommen. Wir reden über den Jugendschutz in Deutschland. Der nächste am Telefon ist Christian aus Schwerin namens Christian. Oder jetzt quasi guten Morgen.
Guten Morgen.
Mein Computer sagt mir, du bist Spielehändler.
Ich habe einen Second Hand Shop und mache ungefähr 50 Prozent meines Umsatzes mit Spielen aus Playstation 2, Xbox und Gamecube und so weiter.
Na dann plauder doch mal aus dem Nähkästchen.
Ja, also bei mir ist es so, wenn junge Leute kommen, 16, 17, wollen ein 18er-Spieler haben, bei mir kriegen sie sie nicht, sondern nur mit den Eltern, also die müssen dann schon mitkommen. Die meisten kommen auch mit und kaufen die Sachen auch. Nur ist es so, muss ich sagen, so 70 Prozent, da klappt das auch. Bei den restlichen 30 Prozent, die sagen dann auch mal nein. Also das ist schon ziemlich interessant.
Also die Eltern kommen, sehen das Spiel und sagen, kaufe ich nicht?
Genau, ja. Also das sind ungefähr 30 Prozent aus meinen eigenen Erfahrungen hier.
Zu den anderen 70 Prozent sagst du denn irgendwas?
Ja, natürlich, ja, mache ich auch. Also ich mache die Eltern auf jeden Fall darauf aufmerksam. Also das ist da und damit. Aber wie gesagt, man kann diese Spiele ja auch nicht verallgemeinern, das ist ja immer das Problem. Man kann ja nicht, ja, wie soll ich sagen, das eine Spiel ist Sohn, das andere Spiel ist Sohn, das haben wir ja heute, ich habe ja zugehört, die Probleme schon, dass diese Bewertungen sehr allgemein sind. Also ich finde, ich bin auch Vater einer siebenjährigen Tochter und die lasse ich nur ordentlich alles machen, an Spielen oder im Internet oder sonst irgendwo. Also da achte ich schon drauf. Und ich denke, wir können in Deutschland so viel verbieten wie wir wollen, es wird immer wieder einen Weg geben. So wie zum Beispiel jetzt, weiß ich, vor ein, zwei Jahren wurde verboten, dass irgendwelche Kopierschutzprogramme auf Deutsch verkauft werden. Ich meine, die kann man sich auch stammend aus dem Internet runterladen und dann trotzdem irgendwelche Kopien knacken, also Originale knacken damit.
Ich glaube, bei diesem Jugendschutz oder jungen Medienschutz geht es auch nicht so sehr um Verallgemeinerung. Das ist schon klar, dass es verschiedene Sorten und Arten von Computerspielen, von Filmen, etc. gibt. Es geht erstmal darum, dass in diesen verschiedenen Inhalte sind, die ein Gremium für kritisch empfunden hat und deswegen gesagt hat, irgendwie Stempel drauf ab 18.
Na klar, aber wie gesagt, das ist halt sehr verallgemeinert. Man kann ja...
Kann ich ganz kurz? Deswegen ist es ja eigentlich deine Aufgabe als Elternteil, okay, sich dieses Spiel zu nehmen, auf die Rückseite das OSK-Siegel, oh, ab 18, naja, ich kann ja mal angucken, was da so drin ist und vielleicht eventuell mir das Film oder das Computerspiel mal durchspielen. Und dann kann ich ja als Elternteil, das ist dein gutes Recht und auch deine Pflicht letztendlich, sagen, will ich das meiner Tochter spielen lassen oder will ich das nicht? Also weil nur du als Elternteil hast ja auch die Ansicht darüber, wie weit oder wie reif dein Kind ist und mit welchen Sachen es schon umgehen kann und wie weit es vielleicht in seiner Medienkompetenz oder überhaupt ist.
Dieser Meinung bin ich ja absolut auch. Also es ist so, ich meine, es heißt USK. Das heißt, das ist eine Empfehlung letztendlich. Für mich als Händler ist es natürlich bindend, aber eigentlich ist es eine Empfehlung. Und ich hab mir jetzt gerade drei Spiele rausgesucht, das ist einmal Ab durch die Hecke, das ist King Kong und das ist Call of Duty. Und da steht eine Pegi-Info drauf. Bei Ab durch die Hecke ist es 3+, Pegi, USK, 6. Dann kommt, das sind gute Beispiele, Peter Jacksons King Kong, das Spiel zum Film, 12 von Pegi und 12 von USK. Und dann kommt Call of Duty, Fein ist Auer. Ballerspiel, 16 Pegi und 18, also rote Keinzeichnung, USK.
Torsten vom CTC kann die Unterschiede zwischen Pegi und USK sich noch mal kurz erläutern.
Was er anspricht, ist genau der Punkt. Da ist eben auch das Problem von Pegi. Pegi ist auf allen Packungen drauf gedruckt, weil es europaweit in vielen Ländern gültig ist, aber in Deutschland eben nicht. In Deutschland haben wir die USK und die Pegi interessiert uns eigentlich gar nicht. Es ist ein nettes System aus unserer Sicht, aber wir haben die USK. Als Elternteil hast du natürlich wahrscheinlich überhaupt keinen Plan und hast eben beide Siegel drauf. Pegi ist zum Teil sogar noch größer als das USK-Siegel, das ja vergleichsweise klein ist. Das heißt, wir haben da auf jeden Fall Verwirrung. Also die Einstufung 3 Plus haben wir einfach nicht. Also in allen Medien haben wir einfach erst mal ohne Altersfreigabe oder dann 6, 3 Plus ist vollkommen unbekannt. Und natürlich funktionieren diese Systeme anders. Also beim Pegi-System wurde dieses Spiel einfach von keinem Gremium begutachtet. Da hat einfach der Produzent das Spiel nach einem Raster am Internet selber klassifiziert. Spiele, die dann eine Bewertung auf 18 kriegen würden, werden dann noch mal näher angesehen. Ansonsten, ab 16 gehen die halt dann so raus, dass es Pegi-Siegel und gut ist. Also jetzt ganz, ganz grob gesagt. Deswegen trägt Pegi da auch durchaus Verwirrung bei, da gebe ich dir recht.
Ich meine eher, dass man vielleicht auch daran sieht, wie unterschiedlich dann auch bewertet wird, welche Gruppe nun gerade da ist, welches Wetter gerade ist oder welche Würfel gerade gefallen sind.
Das hast du ja auch schon in Deutschland. Du hast bei allen Selbstkontrollen wirklich auch die Möglichkeit, Berufen einzulegen als Produzent. Dann tritt ein neues Gremium zusammen und dieses Gremium kann natürlich zu einer anderen Entscheidung kommen. Aber das ist ja auch eben das Wichtige. Das sind eben Medienprodukte, die man sich wirklich ansehen muss und wo man eben unterschiedlicher Ansicht sein kann. Deswegen auch diese fruchtbare Diskussion. Nochmal bei Peggy, es hat dann keiner gesehen. Also da gibt es halt kein Gremium, da ist dann auch das Wetter egal. Aber in der USK natürlich, du kannst Berufe einlegen, neues Gremium, neue Bewertung. Also das ist auf jeden Fall möglich.
Ja, ich meine aber wie gesagt insgesamt ist das zwar ein guter Hinweis und so weiter, aber letztendlich sollten wir auch ein bisschen mehr Eigenverantwortung in Deutschland übernehmen, statt alles zu verbieten. Ich meine, wir haben nur wirklich genug Verbote in Deutschland.
Und um uns im Zweifelsfall einfach darauf zurückziehen zu können und zu sagen, wir haben ein Verbot und darum muss ich jemand kümmern und die Verantwortung ist nicht meine. Das ist nämlich der einfachste und der Holzweg.
Und was verboten ist, gibt es nicht.
Je mehr Verbote man natürlich erteilt, desto mehr muss auch kontrolliert werden.
Richtig.
Und das passiert ja gar nicht. Also wie gesagt, ich sehe es selbst als Händler. Also bei mir war noch nie jemand, der sich mal irgendwie beschwert hat oder so. Hier du hast ein Spiel so und so verkauft. Ich kann natürlich auch keine 12-Jährigen mit 13-Jährigen unterscheiden oder so, weil die haben keinen Ausweis und gar nichts.
Weißt du denn als Händler, welche Strafe dir droht?
Ja, natürlich ja. Das sind schon ein paar Tausend Euro. Nee, da hab ich auch gar keinen Bock drauf. Also ich bestecke dann auch nur mal auf einen 20er, auf einen 30er. Viele kommen auch nicht wieder, weil die Eltern das halt nicht erlaubt haben. Manche haben auch einfach gar keine Lust mitzukommen. Man merkt das auch.
Oder vielleicht nicht mal lustig, da um zu kümmern, was da eigentlich gerade im Laufe der Zeit geht.
Und ich würde es selbst auch nicht mit meinem Gewissen vereinbaren können. Also das muss nicht sein.
Christian, vielen Dank für diese Einblicke aus der Spielebranche. Und schönen Abend nach Schwerin. Der nächste am Telefon ist nämlich Philipp aus Dresden, der nochmal was sagen will zu dieser Amazon-Problematik, die wir vorhin schon hatten, dass man als unter 16-Jähriger ein Girokonto hat und sich dann bei Amazon einfach einen Account haben kann und sich dann die Sachen bestellen kann, die eigentlich erst ab 16 freigegeben sind. Namen Philipp. Hallo. Hab ich das richtig zusammengefasst?
Ja, so ungefähr.
Alles klar.
Es ging eigentlich darum, also ja, grob so mit Amazon hat es zu tun. Und zwar, das ist ja auch bei den ganzen Computerspiele-Zeitschriften, also die ist nie bei, was, PC-Professional oder sowas, sondern bei GameStar.
Wie sie alle heißen?
PC, Games, GameStar und sowas. Die sind ja auch alle ab 16.
Die Zeitschriften meinst du jetzt?
Die Zeitschriften sind ab 16. Also die mit DVDs, wo die Demos dabei sind. Und die Abo-Bestellungen im Internet läuft so ab, sag ich mal, denke ich mal eher ähnlich wie Amazon, dass man dort schon ein Geburtsdatum angeben muss, aber es wird halt auch nie getestet.
Oder im Zweifelsfall bist du einfach im Verteiler drin und die schicken dir die Zeitung raus, ohne dass da irgendjemand sitzt und bei jeder Ausgabe prüft, ob die jetzt sozusagen für denjenigen zugänglich ist. Der Aufwand ist auch gigantisch natürlich.
Aber es ist keine Ausrede. Genau, und den Altersnachweis muss man dort auch erst bringen, wenn man die ab 18. Edition haben möchte. Das heißt, dort muss man dann die Kopie vom Ausweis mit schicken, vorher nie.
Wobei es natürlich im Zeitalter von Photoshop wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr so ein Problem ist.
Das geht ja dort einfach nur noch um die Demos, die halt mitgeliefert werden.
Kommt Frank um die Ecke schon wieder mit einer Hacker-Idee. Ja, das ist ein guter Einwurf auf jeden Fall. Da können sich auch mal die Leute, die diese Computerzeitschriften vertreiben oder herstellen, an die eigene Nase fassen.
Die kriegt man ja dann auch in jedem Zeitungsladen. Und da kontrolliert ja auch quasi keiner.
Im Zweifelsfall ist morgens um 7 am Hauptbahnhof auch mehr Trubel, dass das der Zeitungshändler im Akkord die Zeitung rausgibt und zwischendurch irgendjemand diese Zeitschrift da durchschiebt. Gut, Philipp, hast du vielleicht noch einen Ansatz, wie man das mit dem Jugendschutz drehen kann?
Na, das Jugendschutzproblem war ja noch, sag ich mal, das würde ich jetzt nicht nur so auf das, sag mal, Computerspiele beziehen. Das ist ja eigentlich Medienschutz und das ist ja auch Fernsehen und alles mögliche andere. Wenn man sich jetzt überlegt, wenn man, sag ich mal, grob abends die Nachrichten einschaltet, sieht man ja auch, 50 Prozent davon, in Bagdad haben sich 50 Leute abgeknallt und danach kommt Sturp langsam, wo der Superheld durch die Gegend zieht und alle abknallt. Und da würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt sagen, dass das für die Jugend besser ist. Auch wenn das dann schon 20 oder 22 Uhr im Fernsehen kommt.
Zack, da kommt sofort eine Wortmeldung von Annett.
Genau, es kam 22 Uhr im Fernsehen und da ist die FSF, die Freiwillige Selbstkontrolle Fernsehen, für zuständig, die dann halt nach den Altersbestimmungen sagt, um welche Uhrzeitsachen laufen können. Und in einem vernünftigen Haushalt, die ihre Kinder altersgerecht vielleicht erziehen, ist ein neunjähriger, zehnjähriger eigentlich um 22 Uhr im Bett.
Ach, um 22 Uhr im Fernsehen auf dem Zimmer.
Genau, das haben sie ja sowieso alle.
Kann man Stecker ziehen.
Und ich sag mal, das haben wir heute, ich möchte jetzt nicht irgendwie verspotten, aber das haben wir heute auch schon 12-jährige nach 22 Uhr angerufen. Und ich sag mal, wenn ich dann zum Beispiel weitergucke, die Metal-Szenen in Herder Ringe 2, der war glaube ich ab 12, die sind auch nicht gerade ohne.
Aber es geht ja, also ich denke, das ist davon aber auch nicht, sagen wir mal, verharmlos, in dem Sinne, als dass es jetzt, es geht ja nicht um Gewaltdarstellung, sondern quasi in welchem Kontext diese Gewalt ist.
Ja, aber ich würde jetzt, ich würde deswegen jetzt nicht unbedingt nur die Computerspieler dort die Schuld draufschieben, weil die Gewalt, dort werden die Jugendlichen eigentlich permanent in allen Medien damit konfrontiert.
Klar, deswegen haben wir auch ein sehr umfangreiches System von Kontrollstellen oder von Bewertungsstellen in Deutschland.
Zu Herr der Ringe wollte ich noch ganz kurz was sagen. Soweit ich weiß, ist das sogar auch ein Kinderbuch oder zumindest ein Kinder- und Jugendbuch. Und dann ist es vielleicht auch ein bisschen schwerer zu sagen, weil da kommt natürlich Gewalt vor. Wir machen es erst ab 16 oder 18, wenn die Vorlage schon ein Kinder- oder Jugendbuch ist.
Wobei die Umsetzung, also auch beim letzten Harry Potter Film, der im Kino war, ich sag mal so als 9- 10-Jähriger, mit den Todessern und dem dunklen Mahlen und den Drachen und so. Ich glaube, da schläft man in der Nacht auch nicht gut.
Aber ich sag mal bei Herr der Ringe, wenn man da mal ein bisschen die Vergangenheit von Peter Jackson kennt, dann müsste man schon mal daran denken, dass da die Szenen auch ein bisschen härter sein können.
Worauf spielst du da an?
Ja, also, nein.
Der ist ja soweit ich weiß auch indiziert.
Ja, der ist indiziert. Aber indiziert ist ja nicht verboten.
Richtig, aber wie hast du ihn bekommen? In welchem Rahmen hast du den gesehen?
In welchem Rahmen? Tauschbörsen. Also ich sag mal, sowas kriegt man dann schon relativ schwer noch unter der Ladentheke. Also runtergeladen und dann geguckt halt.
Und konntest du die Indizierung nachvollziehen oder hättest du ihn auch freigegeben für Kinder und Jugendliche?
Ich sag mal, er ist schon hart. Ab 18 ist er in Ordnung, weil die Gewaltdarstellung dazu nie ist natürlich übertrieben. Also auch eigentlich überhaupt nicht nachvollziehbar. Und wer das irgendwie auf eine reale Ebene bezieht, ist für mich ein Spinner. Aber es ist halt auch nichts Leichtes. Also als 16 würde ich das auch noch nicht sehen lassen.
Ich glaube, es geht auch nicht immer darum, dass man irgendwelche Fiktionen auf die reale Ebene zieht, sondern es geht, wenn Sachen zum Beispiel indiziert werden, ganz klar darum, dass bestimmte Sachen verherrlicht werden, zum Beispiel Gewalt.
Es gibt, wenn ich da kurz einwirken darf, es gibt natürlich, besonders bei so Geschichten wie diese Amokläufen, immer auch die Kritik, a, sie sind Computerspiele, b, es ist die Musik. Marilyn Manson hatten sie an der Backe, dann hatten sie Slipknot an der Backe, dann hatten sie auch Cannibal Cows immer mal wieder an der Backe. Also alles Bands, die durchaus im weitesten Sinne irgendwie auch ruppig reagieren und die Musiker sagen dann, hey, was wir hier machen, ist nichts anderes als eine Geschichte erzählen, ein Buch schreiben, das ist bei einem Film ganz genauso, das ist bei einem Buch ganz genauso, aber die Musiker kriegen sie an der Backe, weil die eben auch noch quasi die Kinder aufstacheln und bei Filmen oder bei Büchern oder bei Videos macht sich da überhaupt keiner mit einer Birne. Also da wird mit zwei allerlei Maß gemessen.
Wobei das auch immer eine Entwicklung ist. Also du hast halt immer das aktuellste Medium, ist dann immer Schuld. Also natürlich zu Zeiten, wo es noch keine Videospiele gab, waren es halt schon die Kinofilme und sobald dann Videospiele auftauen. Du wirst merken, in ein paar Jahren sind Filme einfach so etabliert wie Bücher und überhaupt nicht mehr eine Diskussion, weil halt immer neuere Medien im Vordergrund stehen.
Um was denkst du, was es für Diskussionen gab, als die ersten Bücher rauskamen und irgendwie bestimmte Mädchenromane, dass Mädchen zu Leseratten werden und etc.
Als es noch keine Filme groß und keine Bücher gab, gab es einen Typen namens Elvis Presley, der quasi auch der Leibhaftige persönlich war.
Aber da gab es auch schon Bücher, als sollte es noch nicht.
Einen dritten Punkt hab ich eigentlich noch. Und zwar, dass es ja eigentlich auch so ist, dass, sag mal, für die Jugendlichen, wenn sie sich nicht selbst organisieren, eigentlich nichts mehr gibt in der Freizeit. Wenn ich das bei uns sehe, in Dresden werden Jugendclubs an Augenmaß geschlossen. Also wo sich jetzt mal, sag ich, auch Leute, die jetzt vielleicht einen großen Freundeskreis haben oder eher ausgegrenzt sind, auch mal hingehen können, gibt es eigentlich kaum noch jetzt öffentliche Jugendclubs. Die werden halt immer weiter geschlossen. In der Schule muss ein Lehrer vor 30 Schülern unterrichten. Da kann man dann auch wirklich nie von einem Lehrer erwarten, dass der dort das Problem kennt, rausfindet.
Kann man auch nicht, aber man kann es durchaus von den Schülern untereinander, von der Clique, von den Kumpels, von sonstigen erwarten, dass der eine auf den anderen ein bisschen aufpasst.
Ich möchte aber gar nicht raus. Das ist ja auch klar. Aber es wird ja auch immer gesagt, die Lehrer müssten dort mehr aufpassen.
Das ist eine ganz einfache Schuld hin und her Schiebung von Leuten, die zu feige oder zu faul sind, selbst die Verantwortung zu nehmen.
Ich denke aber auch, wir können von unseren Politikern mal ein bisschen fördern, dass für Bildung ein bisschen mehr investiert wird und nicht ein Lehrer vor einer Klasse mit 30 Kindern sitzen muss und nicht der 10. Club schon wieder geschlossen wird und die Kinder sich an der Tankstelle treffen müssen.
Genau, das finde ich eigentlich noch viel schlimmer als immer dieses Schuld hin und her schieben. Das sind wirklich diese Probleme, die eigentlich, dass die Jugend nichts anderes mehr zu tun hat eigentlich, wenn sie nicht selber irgendwas auf die Beine stellt.
Genau, genau.
Dass sie dann eigentlich nur vom Rechner sitzen kann oder sich betrinken kann oder...
Oder vielleicht klöppeln lernt oder sonstige vergesste Handwerke. Philipp, danke für den Anruf. Jetzt habe ich ein schlechtes Gewissen, weil wir haben zwei Leute, die dir extrem lange warten. Zum einen Janos Brehm und zum anderen Axel aus Hohenschönhausen. Der nächste ist Axel.
Bist du noch da?
Ja, bin ich.
Guten Abend.
Du hast jetzt fast eine Stunde gewartet. Entschuldige bitte und danke für die Geduld.
Keine Frage.
Wir waren bei Jugendschutz. Wie funktioniert er? Was sollte besser gemacht werden und was sollte für wen zugänglich gemacht werden?
Da ich relativ zeitig angerufen hatte, hatte ich noch einen ganz anderen Einspumpunkt, nämlich tatsächlich den Erfinder des Betriebssystems, also Linus.
Linus, der als Erster angerufen hat, der Zwölfjährige, der erzählt hat, dass er spürt ab 18 spürt.
Dass er mit einer Brusthaut für die Stolle durch die Gegend schießt. Und an der Stelle habe ich ein richtiges Problem. Nicht weil er 12 Jahre alt ist, sondern weil ich überhaupt damit ein Problem habe. Vielleicht habe ich einfach zu Zeiten, da ich noch mit Waffen zu tun hatte, weil ich halt bei der Armee war, ein bisschen zu viel gesehen habe, was damit schiefgehen kann. Und ich habe ein grundsätzliches Problem, Waffen auf andere Leute zu richten. Bei aller Liebe, das ist kein Spielzeug. Spätestens wenn es in der Realität passiert. Und an der Stelle haben wir in Deutschland ein bisschen ein sehr liberales Waffengesetz, also was mir wesentlich zu liberal ist. Weil wenn ich irgendwelche Waffen, sei es Gasbrugwaffen oder ähnliche verkaufe, die schon auf zwei Meter Entfernung nicht mehr von Arealen zu unterscheiden sind, dann kann ich auch eine gewisse Bedrohungslage verstehen, die aus anderer Richtung passiert. An der Stelle, denke ich, muss man grundsätzlich erst mal irgendetwas ändern.
Das heißt, deine Kinder dürften weder Gotcha noch auch Ego-Shootern am Rechner spielen?
Gotcha definitiv nein. Keine Frage. Ego-Shootern ist so eine Sache auch. Ich habe ein Problem, tatsächlich auch in einer Simulation Waffen auf Leute zu richten. Und wenn mir da jemand sagt, ich muss doch da aber taktische Überlegungen hin und her, dann ist das eigentlich nur eine Verbesserung der Simulation. Das ist nicht was einfach Blödes wie ein Schiess, wie ein Tontaubenschießen oder was weiß ich, irgendwie auf Bälle, mit Bällen auf Pyramiden werfen. Ist so doch irgendwie nur eine Verbesserung und eine Erhöhung des Anreiz. Nun kann man natürlich die Sache weit ausmalen und sagen, okay, dann darfst du auch keine Schachsimulation zu lassen. Spätestens mit dem Felsensieh-Schach, wo die Leute sich gar heftig um die Ecke bringen oder gar beim Harry Potter Teil 1, wo die Figuren sich auch mehr gegenseitig erst mal. Ist das schon natürlich ein Problem.
Aber Axel, du darfst nicht, du darfst nicht, du darfst nicht, das haben wir ja heute schon geklärt, führt ja eigentlich nur dazu, dass man sagt, jetzt will ich erst recht. Also muss es anders funktionieren.
Das funktioniert auch nicht. Einen kleinen Gedankensprung, der aber im Endeffekt wieder zum Ziel führt. Ich habe vor einiger Zeit einen interessanten Vortrag des Leiters des Kriminalinstitutes in Hannover, KFN, Pfeiffer, Christian, Christoph Pfeiffer gehört, der eine ganz interessante Geschichte erzählte. Der hat eine Umfrage oder eine Studie gemacht, in dem er die Leute gefragt hat, was sie glauben, woran die meisten Leute heutzutage sterben. Bei den Zwölf- bis Sechzehnjährigen kam heraus, dass sie glauben, dass 30% der Leute an Gewaltverbrechen sterben. Und an der Stelle glaube ich, haben wir richtig wesentlich etwas zu tun mit dem Medienkonsum. Und zwar nicht nur mit Computerspielen, die immer als das Böse hingestellt werden, die ich sicherlich auch nicht für sonderlich schön finde, insbesondere dann, wenn es darum geht, Leute möglichst qualvoll vom Leben zum Tode zu befördern, wie es bei irgendwelchen Mafiaspielen vielleicht sein mag. Vielleicht noch mehr Punkte, die qualvoller ich den Herrn umbringe. Da würden wir also sozusagen eine Foltersimulation erfinden. Da ist dann schon ein Problem. Aber das ist natürlich wirklich nur die Spitze des Eisbergs. Das Hauptproblem ist ja ein Großteil privater Medien, die ja nicht das Interesse haben, Informationen zu verbreiten, sondern die das Interesse haben, Geld zu verdienen. Das heißt, das verkauft sich eigentlich wesentlich besser, wenn ich irgendeine Nachricht verbreite, aber sage, und im Anschluss einen Bericht über den kleinen Sohn, der seinen Vater erschießt. Und wenn das im Nachhinein dann auch bloß herauskommt, dass das irgendwo weit weg ist und gar nicht mal in Deutschland, so muss ich doch dann an der Stelle tatsächlich sagen, das große Problem ist ein privates Nachrichtenmedium. Und wenn man sich in Nachrichten genau auf dieses verlässt, ist man rettungslos verloren. Erschreckt war ich vom Herrn Pfeiffer dann, dass es eigentlich eine Bankrotterklärung war von ihm, dass er sagt, wir können uns nicht dagegen wehren. Wir können den Privatsendern es nicht verbieten. Privatmedien, Fernsehen, Radio, können es nicht verbieten. Wir können bloß irgendwelche Richtlinien schaffen, dass manche Sachen nicht zu jedem Zeitpunkt zu sehen sind. Aber im Endeffekt können wir überhaupt nichts dagegen machen, wie und was sie mit Gewalt in der Öffentlichkeit tun.
Axel, Luft holen, hier kommen sofort zwei Wortmeldungen.
Ich wollte auch nochmal ganz klar sagen, wir wollen auch nicht verbieten. Ich will auf jeden Fall nicht verbieten. Das würde für mich in die Richtung Zensur gehen. Und Zensur ist was, was ich für völlig negativ halte. Jugendmedienschutz beschäftigt sich mit Vorschlägen, mit Bestimmungen, aber nicht mit dem Verbot bestimmter Inhalte, zum Beispiel in Nachrichtensendungen. Da geht es dann darum, um welche Uhrzeiten die gesendet werden. Und ich ganz kurz als Erwachsener möchte mir auch gerne das Recht herausnehmen, selber zu entscheiden, weil ich mir zum Beispiel sage, dass ich medienkompetent bin, welche Nachrichten ich mir angucke und dann selbst zu unterscheiden, was halte ich für wahre Münze und was nicht.
Ich weiß es nicht, ob man manchmal nicht mal überlegen sollte, für sich privat, muss ich das wirklich alles haben, oder ist es vielleicht eine bessere Idee für die Allgemeinheit, wenn die Allgemeinheit darauf verzichtet?
Das ist quasi das, was Annett gerade sagte. Ich kann für mich selber entscheiden, welche Nachrichten ich nicht angucke, aber einen großen Sack zu nehmen, alle reinzustecken und drauf zu hauen, ist wahrscheinlich...
Ich habe immer ein kleines Problem, ein wirklich kleines Problem, nicht groß, ein kleines Problem damit, wenn alle Leute sagen, ja, ich fühle mich dann in meiner persönlichen Freiheit eingegrenzt. Persönliche Freiheit um jeden Preis habe ich dann ein Problem damit. Und wenn es um den Preis ist, dass ich dann tatsächlich zwar für mich alles machen und tun kann, aber der hat übertrieben gesagt, der Rest der Welt um mich im Sumpf versinkt, dann ist da mit der persönlichen Freiheit eine gewisse Grenze zu ziehen. Darüber kann man jetzt, glaube ich, lange streiten, führt uns jetzt vom Thema weg.
Richtig.
Da ist wirklich nur die Frage, vielleicht sollte man manchmal auch persönliche Interessen ein bisschen hinten anstellen.
Du bist ein erwachsener Mann, du kannst selber entscheiden, was du dir antun willst und was nicht. Und der Spruch heißt nicht umsonst, sich über irgendwas ärgern.
Aber das Thema ist natürlich schon auch Medienkompetenz. Insofern kommen wir da nicht ganz vom Thema ab. Weil letztendlich geht es ja darum, auf was für ein innenpolitisches Klima herrscht. Und wenn innenpolitisches Klima herrscht von Bedrohung, Angst und wir werden alle Gewaltopfer, dann hat es natürlich auch Auswirkungen auf die Politik, vor allem auf die Innenpolitik, auf die Gesetze, die gemacht werden, auf irgendwelche Überwachungsmechanismen, die geschaffen werden. Und da setzt natürlich sehr wohl wieder die Medienkompetenz ein.
Und an der Stelle ist natürlich dann gleich wieder die bitterböse Frage, die sofort drei Meilen nach Verschwörungstheorie riecht. Hat man nicht ein gewisses Interesse daran. Um eben seine Gesetze durchsetzen zu können?
Also ich war auch gerade ein bisschen, als ich hörte, wer das gesagt hatte, muss ich halt auch sagen, okay, naja, klar, aus der Ecke hätte ich sowas natürlich auch erwartet.
Kann vielleicht noch jemand was zu Herrn Christian Pfeiffer erzählen?
Ich kann nicht viel zu ihm sagen. Ich habe also jetzt alles, was er veröffentlicht, nicht gelesen. Es begegnet einem gelegentlich, wenn man sich mit dem Thema beschäftigt, beziehungsweise er kann ihm auch relativ schnell begegnen, also gerade nach Emstetten hat er sich auch hervorgetan, indem er die USK abschaffen wollte, weil er meinte, sie funktioniert offenbar nicht. Ich finde Pfeiffer, was ich von ihm kenne, sehr problematisch. Und eben auch das Genannte kann man natürlich ziemlich leicht auseinandernehmen. Dass Kinder und Jugendliche falsche Zahlen wiedergeben oder ein anderes Bild wiedergeben, das ist, glaube ich, fast ein Charakteristiker von Kindheit und Jugendlichkeit, ist für mich überhaupt kein Beleg, er hat eine Art Medienwirkung, deswegen finde ich Pfeiffer den meisten Sachen, die er sagt und macht, recht pfeifelhaft. Aber ich bin trotzdem dankbar für seine Erwähnung und ich bin Axel auch dankbar für die Erwähnung des Privatfernsehens, weil das ist natürlich ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Es ist eben kein öffentlich-rechtliches Angebot, was uns diktiert wird, sondern es ist schon auch in gewisser Weise das, was wir sehen wollen. Also dass die Privaten mit diesem Programm, das du jetzt kritisierst, erfolgreich sind, zeigt ja auch, dass da ein gewisser Bedarf sein muss. Sonst würden sie es dann nicht senden. Die Privaten würden nicht senden, was gerne guckt, oder?
Ja, da ist nur die Frage, wer wirklich den Bedarf schafft und wodurch der Bedarf geschaffen wird. Aber ich glaube, das können wir jetzt hier nicht auseinandernehmen.
Wirklich, das ist eine andere Baustelle, das ist ein anderer Topf, den wir hier aufmachen. Das führt absolut zu weit. Wir haben nicht mal mehr eine halbe Stunde. Möchtest du noch was sagen, Frank? Sonst wünsche ich Axel jetzt eine schöne Nacht.
Genau, wünschen wir ihm. Ich wollte mich noch eine kleine Ankündigung machen.
Axel, danke für den Anruf. Ich würde sagen, eine kurze, gewaltverherrlichende Musik, dann deine Ankündigung, dann die Nachrichten. Ja, Chaosradio 125 auf Fritz.
Steht auf Jonas.
Doch Jonas liebt Vanessa.
Vanessa, der Kerb mit Lars zusammen dort, der findet Melanie besser.
Die allerdings steht eher auf Tim.
Jennifer jedoch ist verliebt mit Kevin.
Tobias will Schauborn, Annika und Annika eigentlich auch auf ihn.
Doch Pech, wenn es schon lange der Schwarm ihrer besten Freundin. Hagen erschießt Sebastian. Sven überfährt Hagen.
Christopher erwirkt Sven und wird von Janik erschlagen.
Benjamin macht Lukas aller und wird von Nils erstochen. Alexander killt Thorsten und Felix und wird erschossen.
So viel dazu. Klokator, Alter Mann. Jetzt wollte Frank noch was sagen.
Genau, ich hab nämlich zwei Ankündigungen. Zum einen ist natürlich das Chaos Communication Camp, was im August stattfindet, von 8 bis 12 an dem Wochenende, wo ihr alle ganz herzlich gebeten seid zu kommen. Das ist eine große Hacker Party, wo wir alle unsere Zelte mitbringen, unsere Computer und es gibt Internet, es gibt Vorträge und es wird immer eine ganz großartige Veranstaltung. Das andere ist, wer sich von euch aus dem Raum Berlin für so Mikrocontroller, das sind also kleine programmierbare Chips, Mikrocontroller halt interessiert und damit selber gerne basteln will. Da haben wir jetzt eine Workshopreihe bei uns, die wir anbieten, nämlich die nächsten Donnerstage. Los geht's nächste Woche, also jetzt nicht morgen, sondern in eine Woche, so ungefähr um 20 Uhr bei uns in der Marienstraße 11, wo man lernt, mit den Dingern was zu löten, was zu basteln und die dann auch zu programmieren. Wenn ihr da Interesse habt, kommt einfach hin oder schreibt auch eine Mail an mail.berlin.ccc.de.
Und wenn ihr das nicht macht, kriegt ihr nächstes Weihnachten keine Geschenke.
Sie sind von einem einfachen Schülerkombot zur begehrtesten Indieband des Planeten aufgestiegen. Montag, 9. Juli. Ab 20 Uhr in der Kolumbiale Berlin. Die Arctic Monkeys live. Rodziger Rock'n'Roll. Und das hört man.
2 nach halb 1.
Fritz-Info. Bundeskanzlerin Merkel hat dem neuen britischen Premierminister Brown zu seinem Amtsantritt gratuliert. In einer Pressemitteilung hieß es, Merkel habe zudem den Wunsch geäußert, die enge und vertrauensvolle Zusammenarbeit zwischen beiden Regierungen vorzuführen. Der bisherige Schatzkanzler Brown war heute von Königin Elisabeth II mit der Regierungsbildung beauftragt worden. Er will morgen sein Kabinett vorstellen. Sein Vorgänger Blair wurde inzwischen offiziell zum Sonderbeauftragten des Nahostquartetts ernannt. Bahnchef Medorn bleibt bis 2011 im Amt. Der Aufsichtsrat des Unternehmens teilte nach einer Sitzung mit, dass der Vertrag des 64-Jährigen um drei Jahre verlängert werde. Damit kann Medorn die geplante Privatisierung der Bahn weiter vorantreiben. Der Bundestag hat im November grundsätzlich entschieden, das letzte große Staatsunternehmen in Deutschland bis 2009 in Teilen an die Börse zu bringen. Über das erforderliche Gesetz wird aber weiter gestritten. Bei neun Anschlägen Mirags sind mindestens 27 Menschen getötet worden. Eine Angaben von Sicherheitskräften starben bei der Explosion einer Autobombe in einem Schiitenviertel Bagdads am Abend zehn Menschen. Bei der Detonation eines Sprengensatzes auf einem Markt im Norden der Hauptstadt seien fünf Menschen getötet worden. In Bagdad wurden, den Angaben zur Folge, außerdem die Leichen von 21 Ermordeten entdeckt. Die Hintergründe der Tat sind noch unklar. Die Berliner Feuerwehr ist wegen des Sturms heute über 90 Mal ausgerückt. Wie die Polizei mitteilte, stürzen wegen des starken Windes mit Orkanartigen Böen zahlreiche Bäume um und Bauteile wurden abgerissen. In Kreuzberg kippte ein Baum auf einen fahrenden BVG-Bus. Fünf parkende Autos wurden dabei beschädigt. Menschen kamen aber nicht zu Schaden. In der Nacht wird der Wind weniger und der Regen lässt auch langsam nach. Es kühlt ab auf 12 bis 9 Grad und am Tag bleibt es weiterhin wechselhaft bei 17 bis 19 Grad. Der Verkehr Fritz A12 Berliner Ring Richtung Frankfurt-Oder zwischen Mürose und dem Grenzübergang Frankfurt-Oder gibt Stau, die Lkw-Spur ist blockiert. Bitte fahrt vorsichtig in das Stauende ran. Ansonsten sind die Straßen frei und wir wünschen eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 101, 5 dann Fritz in Eisenhütten statt.
Heiliger Schroes, ich glaube es war 1980 oder 81, aber nagel mich jetzt darauf nicht wirklich fest. Abwärts der Computer-Stadt im Chaos Radio 125, dem Blue Moon immer am letzten Mittwoch auf Fritz. Wir reden heute über Jugendschutz. Ich mach jetzt mal die Anmoderation eins kurz. Ich glaube, ihr habt mitbekommen, worum es geht. Wir haben nicht mehr so viel Zeit. Deswegen jetzt ganz schnell eine nach dem anderen mit kurzen Statements. Ich hoffe, es ist für euch okay. Der Erste am Telefon ist Jan aus Bremen. Guten Abend, Jan.
Erwider ich mal. Mir gerade mal aufgefallen ist, allein die Nachrichten hier, die eben eingeblendet wurden, begannen damit, dass es 27 Tote im Irak gab durch einen Terroranschlag.
Ja, sollen wir das nicht melden und sollen stattdessen sagen, dass die Gänseblümchen den Nichts wieder blühen?
Ich meinte nur so. Und dann kam danach noch ein paar Details, wo man irgendwie Leichen gefunden hat und so. Also es scheint sehr vom Medien um abhängig zu sein, ob sich darüber irgendjemand aufregt. Vor jetzt anderthalb Wochen oder so wurde es gerade im Radio ja auch sehr breit getreten, dass man irgendwie 15 fast tote Kinder in einem Weißenhaus festgekettet gefunden hat und so, ja.
Das sind, du, Jan, das sind die Dinge, die auf dieser Welt wirklich passieren.
Genau. Was ist also, und kein, darüber, es wird sich weniger in den Medien jedoch darüber aufgeregt, was tatsächlich passiert, als das, was irgendwie auf dem Bildschirm passiert.
Ich glaube, die Diskussion führt jetzt gerade ein bisschen weit weg. Und nur um das ganz kurz zu erklären, die Medien, also quasi wir in den Nachrichten, sind nicht dazu da, sich darüber aufzuregen, dass so was passiert, sondern sie sind dazu da, darüber zu berichten, dass so was passiert.
Ja, und das ist ja auch sehr erstrebenswert.
Richtig.
Nur darin erfährt man wesentlich brutalere Dinge als das, was auf dem Bildschirm passiert.
Du meinst, was in Computerspielen passiert. Oder in Filmen oder bei Büchern.
Womit es wieder ein Thema wäre. Ich habe früher beides gerne gespielt, sowohl an Real Tournament und was ja an sich völlig hohl ist und auch ziemlich gewalttätig. Kann man anders nicht sagen. Das erste bin ich die Abklatsche, die danach kam. Jedoch als Mehrspielerspiel sehr interessant ist, weil es Teamfähigkeit fördert und voraussetzt. Weil als Einzelgänger man keine Chance hat. Auf gerselben Enden jedoch basiert das, meiner Meinung nach, noch wesentlich besseres Spiel, wenn es auch schlecht vergleichbar ist, Deus Ex. Das ist ebenfalls ein sehr gewalttätiges Spiel. Anders kann man es nicht bezeichnen.
Warte mal, ich breche dich jetzt kurz ab, bevor wir weiter über die Details dieser Spiele reden. Du bist 18 oder 19, rufst aus Bremen jetzt an, und sagst, du hast die Spiele gespielt. Wann hast du damit angefangen? Mit welcher Freigabe waren die damals? Wie bist du da herangekommen?
Also die sind alle zusammen ab 18. In der deutschen Version. Ich hatte die internationale Version von beiden.
Und du hast die aus dem Netz?
Nein. Ich habe die von einem Bekannten, der die international Version damals übers Netz bestellt hat.
Ach so, und der hat sich nicht mal mit dir darüber geredet?
Doch, das hat auch für einige Konflikte gesorgt. Irgendwann hatte ich meine Eltern überzeugt, dass sie mich das haben spielen lassen, nachdem sie sich das angeguckt haben und meine Reaktionen darauf sich angeguckt haben.
Wie hast du das geschafft, sie zu überzeugen?
In dem, dass ich erst mal quasi einen Dickkopf markiert habe und das Spiel hier hat, das haben sie natürlich nicht zugelassen. Sie haben dann gesagt, hier steht 18 drauf, erstmal soll ich mir das angucken. Und dann habe ich ihnen gezeigt, was diese Spiele, ja, was die bewirken auf mich, wie ich sie spiele und was das Ziel dabei ist.
Was bewirken denn diese Computerspiele bei dir?
Ähm, damals durchaus aufputschend und so, ja. Und kurzfristig auch aggressionsfördernd, dann durchaus, ja. Weil sie einfach einen sehr unter Stress setzen, wenn man, und das für sie schwer zu unterscheiden war ursprünglich.
Okay, pass auf um die Frage, weil jetzt ein bisschen die Zeit wegläuft und ehe wir jetzt hier noch Unreal Tournament und Deus Ex weiter... Pass auf, Jan, an dich die Frage, würdest du heute als 19-Jähriger, der du ja quasi freien Zugang zu all diesen Dingern hast, würdest du einem Freund von dir oder deinen Geschwistern, die wesentlich jünger sind als du, solche Dinge an die Hand drücken und sagen kannst du machen?
Ich würde da so mit ihm reden und dann beurteilen, ob ich jetzt verantworten kann diese Informationen, denn das sind ja Informationen, die diese Spiele an sie weiterzugeben.
War ein eindeutiges Ja hin, mit wir müssen drüber reden.
Also nicht pauschal, aber ich kenne durchaus 14-Jährige, denen ich das ohne Bedenken übergeben würde.
Alles klar, danke für deinen Anruf, Jan. So, der nächste, Entschuldigung Leute, aber es läuft echt die Zeit weg und den Rest können wir auf fritz.de noch weiter diskutieren. Deswegen müssen wir jetzt ein bisschen ruppig sein. Nächster am Telefon, wartet schon lange, ist Ben aus Kreuzberg 24. Hallo Ben. Danke für die Geduld.
Ja, kein Problem. Auf jeden Fall.
Wir waren gerade bei Altersfreigaben. Jan hat es ja auch wieder erzählt. Er hat mit unter 18 schon Spiele bekommen, die über 18 sind. Und es war eigentlich ein Leichtes, die Dinger zu zocken. Was hältst du davon?
Na ja, kommt auf meinen Punkt zu. Vor allen Dingen, ich sage es einfach mal so, Altersfreigabe ist witzig, aber irgendwie dann noch sinnlos. Vor allen Dingen in einem Zeitalter, wo es ein Medium gibt, was quasi keine Zensur in der Legen ist. Ich habe es schon in der Berufsschule festgestellt, zum Beispiel ein Gott, wenn da ein neues PC-Spiel draußen ist, dann wird es rumgereicht. Da muss man, wo es die Rohlinge rausgehen, fertig.
Und wie gehen wir damit um?
Ja, ich zock selbst recht gerne, ich finde es gut, mal so gesagt. Am Ende, na gut, den Film tut es weh.
Darum geht es aber gar nicht so. Die Frage ist, würdest du es trotzdem befürworten, dass du dieses Spiel an unter 14-Jährige weitergibst?
Ja, es gibt einige Beispiele, wo ich irgendwie, ich sag mal so, wo ich echt mal eine Zweifel hätte. Also es gibt manche Sachen, die will ich irgendwie Leuten nicht antun. Das macht die Motte, dass sie halt wirklich traumatisiert werden könnten.
Du selber packst es?
Ja, ach, ich zock ja schon seit Jahren. Und ich hab auch schon vom Spielen oder vom Filmen her irgendwie auch schon die schlimmsten Sachen gesehen.
Also du sagst, differenzieren und nicht jedem einfach so pauschal in die Hand drücken. Und eine pauschale Altersfreigabe, wie das ab 16 und sobald man diese 16er Schallmauer durchbrochen hat, kann man dir das alles zutrauen. Ist in dem Fall nicht praktikal.
Ganz ehrlich, die Eltern tragen eine Verantwortung. Die Härte der Medien an sich hat sich verändert, kann man jetzt auch schon am Fernsehprogramm feststellen. Als ich aufgewachsen bin, liegten andere Sachen um 22 Uhr, die jetzt am Nachmittag laufen oder so.
Kannst du dafür ein Beispiel geben?
Ja, okay, das hat vielleicht was mit einem persönlichen Erlebnis zu tun. Ich hatte als 8-Jähriger, 7-Jähriger, wurde mir ziemlich ängstlich, als ich gesehen habe, als bei Grandins eins, die Grandins irgendwie geschmolzen sind.
Oder wenn die Critters sich irgendwie reingebissen haben.
Ja, wie vorletzte Woche oder so, lief es um Sonntag zum Mittagessen. Das ist halt eine komische Sache.
Das ist eben was, woran man gewöhnt ist als Matrix 1. Ganz andere Baustelle als Matrix 1 im Kino war. Da haben wir alle gesessen, waren in Sessel gedrückt. Und dann kommt Matrix 2, 3 und du sagst, ja, ich hab schon gesehen.
Wie gesagt, dieser Song von Knack Carter hat schon ziemlich gut darauf gestimmt. Die meisten Eltern wahrscheinlich darauf reagieren.
Pass auf, Ben, wir schalten mal rüber zu Björn nach Hannover. Weil Björn hat einen Vorschlag, der bei der Dexussion auch immer wieder kommt, zum Thema Mediennutzung und wie geht man damit um. Dir erstmal vielen Dank und schönen Abend nach Kreuzberg.
Hallo Björn.
Hallo.
Grüße dich, du bist 24, rufst aus Hannover an.
Genau.
Und hast den Vorschlag des Medienführerscheins. Der kommt ja immer wieder mal gerne. Kannst du das mal erläutern?
Ja, also in meiner Fallstellung nach ist das so eine Einstellung der Eltern, vielleicht unter psychologischer Einwirkung, also aus psychologischer Unterstützung, dass eben für Kinder angegeben wird, inwieweit die Medien konsumieren dürfen, die rüde Sprache enthalten, Gewalt enthalten, Sexualität enthalten, sodass die Eltern sagen können, mein Kind darf bis Punkt 5 Gewaltspiele spielen und gewalttätige Musiker und solche Geschichten und bis zwei sexuelle Inhalte konsumieren und solche Geschichten.
Wie bis zwei sexuelle Inhalte?
Ich hab mal so eine Fantasieskala genommen von 1 bis 10.
Ach so quasi so ein Zahlenlevel, dass man sagt wird, das ist grün, rot, blau, gelb.
Genau.
Alles klar.
Das ist eigentlich mein Vorschlag, weil ohne diesen Ausschuss würde es einfach nichts geben. Dann müssten die Kinder ihre Eltern darauf drängen, dieses Ding auszufüllen.
Ach so, jetzt verstehe ich, dass jeder, der in irgendeiner Form Medien konsumiert, also ein Laden geht, sowas kauft, so eine Berechtigungskarte irgendwie rausgeben muss, oder wie?
Bei den Erwachsenen kann man das ja dann nicht mehr so wirklich kontrollieren.
Könnte man mit dem Schülerausweis oder der Monatskarte koppeln, irgend sowas, irgendeine Idee schwebt dir vor, oder?
Ja, ganz genau.
Und dann ist da hinten grüner, blauer oder gelber Punkt drauf und der, der es verkauft, sagt dann, zeig ich mal deine Schnipselkarte da.
Genau.
Und anhand derer wird dann entschieden, ob das freigegeben wird oder nicht. Kann man doch aber auch sein lassen, wenn man sich einfach so einen Schülerausweis zeigen lässt, da steht ein Geburtstag drauf.
Ja, aber diese Altersfeigabe differenziert nicht so gut, wie ich finde, wie diese Tabelle.
Ich glaube, ich verstehe ungefähr, worauf du hinauswirst und zwar wieder auf das Thema, dass sich Eltern ja mit ihren Kindern und mit den Inhalten beschäftigen müssen. Aber so ein Medienführerschein, wie du ihn gerade beschreibst, ist glaube ich von den meisten Kindern, die sowohl technikversiert sind als wahrscheinlich total einfach zu kopieren. Und B würde es den Eltern glaube ich so ein bisschen wieder die Verantwortung aus der Hand nehmen zu sagen, so Kind, ich nehme dich jetzt an die Hand und ich gehe mit dir in die Videothek oder in den Buchladen etc. und kaufe mit dir das Spiel.
Gut, aber das machen die ja in der Praxis eh nicht. Also insofern wäre es zumindest vielleicht doch ein erster Ansatz, dass die Eltern wenigstens sich einmal Gedanken machen, was soll man Kind eigentlich sehen?
Ich glaube nicht, dass Eltern, die das was ich gerade beschrieben habe sowieso keinen Bock drauf haben, dann Bock drauf haben sich so ein Formular vielleicht auszufüllen, sich gezielt Gedanken darüber zu machen und das auszufüllen. Die werden das dann einfach so, ich sag jetzt mal, frei Schnauze ausfüllen. So, muss ja schnell fertig werden und mein Kind drängt hier gerade, weil es wäre das, weiß ich, Doom 3.
Mama, ich brauch hier noch meinen Ausweis, ich will mir noch ein Ballerspiel holen, und dann hast du noch irgendwie fünf Marke, ich brauch Kondome. Was, Kondome?
Das wär das Problem an der Sache, aber das ist dann wieder eine Sache der Verwirklichung.
Wo kann denn angesetzt werden? Wir hatten schon bei der Medienkompetenz von Lehrern, da waren wir schon, dass viele Lehrer überhaupt nicht bereit sind, sich mit solchen Dingen auseinanderzusetzen. Sie müssen sich ja nicht zocken, aber wenigstens wissen, worum es geht. Mit der Musik zu beschäftigen, überhaupt sich mit der Lebenswirklichkeit ihrer Schüler zu beschäftigen. Dass die Eltern oft zu faul sind oder zu beschäftigt sind, um sich damit zu beschäftigen, was ihre Sprösslinge da machen. Dass man da doch irgendwo anfangen müsste. Also das Problem der Frage, wer ist dafür eigentlich verantwortlich? Wer muss sich darum kümmern? Muss man nicht eigentlich da ansetzen?
Ja, das müsste bei den Lehrern dann aber schon Teil des Studiums sein. Ich weiß nicht, ob das so gut zu verwirklichen ist. Da müsste man ja Professoren ein Killerspiel unterrichten, in Anführungszeichen.
Aber wie ist denn das im Studium heute? Weiß das jemand?
Also ich bin ja Pädagogik- oder Erziehungswissenschafts-Student und ich kenne auch so ein paar Lehrämter. Und mittlerweile gibt es da schon die Tendenzen einer Umstrukturierung, dass das Schulsystem an sich nicht mehr auf Frontalunterricht basieren sollte, sondern auf dieser Kompetenzvermittlung, wo halt eine Teil Medienkompetenz wäre. Und da ist ganz klar ein Problem, warum das auch noch nicht irgendwie so Schlag auf Schlag umgesetzt werden konnte, auch nach PISA zum Beispiel nicht, dass es halt noch keine Lehrer gab, die genau auf solche Unterrichtsformen ausgebildet waren. Weil bisher, wenn ich mir so das Lehramtsstudium angeguckt habe, war halt sehr wenig Pädagogik dabei. Aber ich glaube, das wird sich in Zukunft ändern.
Na, wollen wir auf jeden Fall hoffen. Björn, danke für deinen Anruf und schönen Abend nach Hannover. No, ebenfalls. Bevor wir hier einen Stecker ziehen, kriegt Sebastian aus Neukölln das Schlusswort. Hallo Sebastian. Hallo. Du hast sehr lange gewartet, auch dir vielen Dank für die Geduld.
Ja, natürlich.
Okay, das Schlusswort ist deins.
Okay, prima. Also ich wollte jetzt zum Ende nicht mehr resignativ wirken, aber ich denke, dass mit dem Einführen des Internets hier in Deutschland generell solchen Problematiken eigentlich Tür und Tor irgendwie geöffnet wurden. Also da ist einfach mal wirklich alles möglich. Und egal, wie man es regulieren will oder nicht, sobald der Staat, finde ich, einfach die kompetenten Leute einfach nicht inne hat, die sich mit solchen Thematiken auskennen, was das Technische angeht, dann hinkt man immer hinterher. Und ich denke auch, dass das hauptsächlich wirklich eine Erziehungsfrage ist. Also man muss mit dieser Problematik leben und man muss die Problematik einfach akzeptieren, dass es solche Sachen gibt. Man muss einfach seine Kinder erziehen, wie sie später damit umgehen werden, weil wegkriegen tut man sie einfach wirklich nicht.
Na und man muss sich selber in seinem bestehenden Weltbild immer mal wieder neu justieren und neu korrigieren und sich auf neue Sachen einlassen.
Das stimmt. Also ich denke auch zum Beispiel Pornografie, zum Beispiel, was ja glaube ich noch gar nicht angesprochen ist. Also jeder Mensch, der irgendwie Zugang zum Web über einen Browser hat, kann damals sogar noch über Google Sachen suchen, die natürlich jetzt rausgenommen wurden. Aber selbst auf Indexseiten von ganz normalen Webseiten sind eindeutige Hardcore-Pornografische Bilder zu sehen für die Jugendlichen. Das ist überhaupt gar kein Problem. Man kann dieses Ding einfach, das geht nicht mehr rückgängig zu machen.
Das wird auf jeden Fall, denke ich, wieder ein Thema werden und damit verbunden auch die Geschlechterbilder, die da transportiert werden.
Aber auch das ist ein anderer Topf.
Absolut, ja klar. Aber betrifft man auch wieder den Jugendmedienschutz und da können wir dann eventuell so ein bisschen von der Gewaltdebatte wegkommen. Aber ich denke, Pornografie wird wieder ein Thema werden. Wie damals bei der Videowelle eigentlich auch.
Genau, also es war schon mit der Jugend immer ein Problem. Damals war es, als ich jung war, also also...
Ja, du bist 26 komm.
Jugendlich war, da war es das Problem, zum Beispiel, wie beschafft man sich Alkohol. Sobald es irgendwelche zwischenmenschlichen Beziehungen gibt und man hat Bekanntschaften, dann wird es gekauft von jemandem, der es darf. Also, man kommt da immer ran, egal wie. Und gerade, wie auch schon gesagt wurde, dass einfach mal die Kids heutzutage so technisch versiert werden, dass sie den Eltern des blauen Himmels erzählen können. Und man kann einfach da nichts machen.
Na doch, man kann genau da ansetzen.
Inwiefern? Die Eltern bilden?
Ja, definitiv.
Ja, gut, das wäre auf jeden Fall eine Sache, die...
Also ich muss einfach, ich muss als Vater oder Mutter einfach in der Lage sein, rauszufinden, was auf dem Rechner meines Kindes ist. Also das muss ich einfach können. Wenn ich das nicht kann, muss ich dieses Wissen nachholen.
Genau, das stimmt. Aber dafür ist auf jeden Fall das Interesse der Eltern notwendig.
Ja, aber das setzt sich mal voraus, wenn ich Kinder habe.
Ich glaube, in dem Moment, wo sich die Eltern wirklich auch für die Kinder interessieren und mit den Kindern gemeinsam am PC sitzen, ist es vielleicht auch gar nicht mehr nötig, dass die Eltern die Kinder hinterherschnüffeln, was sie auf dem PC haben. Sondern wenn einfach dieses Vertrauen da ist, dass man sich auch Sachen gemeinsam angucken kann oder dass die Kinder von sich aus bestimmte Sachen vielleicht nicht ansehen, dann wäre das natürlich noch besser, als dass die Eltern quasi den Kindern hinterherschnüffeln müssen und schauen, dass die da nichts verboten ist, in Anführungszeichen angucken.
Genau, das sehe ich genauso. Ich würde auch als Elternteil, wenn ich mal Kinder haben sollte, einfach aus Respekt vor meinem Kind nicht auf die Idee kommen, eigentlich auszuspionieren, was der da macht.
Also ich wollte jetzt auch nicht, dass Eltern ihren Kindern hinterherschnüffeln, aber sie sollten in etwa auf dem Level der Kinder einfach sein und sich auch mit Computern auskennen und auch wissen, was einfach gerade los ist.
Anstatt zu sagen, Eltern, Lehrer, auch große Brüder oder Schwestern sind auch angesprochen, genauso wie Cousins und Neffen und Nichten und wer auch immer da ist oder Kumpels, anstatt zu sagen, finde ich scheiße, finde ich doof, lieber mal fragen, was ist denn das, erklär mir das mal, lass mich mal reingucken.
Genau, aber ich habe die Befürchtung, dass dieses Interesse wirklich zurückgeht. Also wenn man sich mal anguckt, was gerade auch hier, ich sag mal in der Köln, was man da so trifft in der U-Bahn, also es ist schon wirklich komisch. Also man zweifelt schon wirklich an so ein paar Sachen. Hm, was wachsen da für Generationen ran? Also es ist wirklich komisch.
Dann sieh zu, dass du dich um deine eigenen Kinder kümmerst.
Ja, natürlich. Eine Sache wollte ich gerne noch sagen. Ich hab das auch schon gepostet, dass ich so ein bisschen vermisst habe, gerade wenn die Leute oder die Jugendlichen, die so Ego-Shooter und so weiter spielen, auch in der Sendung jetzt schieben die immer so ein bisschen diese Strategieproblematik.
Ach, du bist der Bademeister. Der Bademeister aus dem Fritz-Board, da ist er.
Na ja, dann brauch ich ja nicht sagen. Also für die, die es noch nicht gelesen haben, ich finde schon, dass diese Taktik das immer versucht so ein bisschen abzumindern. Also ich finde, man kann es nicht wirklich auf Taktik schieben. Es bleibt dabei einfach, egal welchen Weg es nun nimmt, ob Taktik oder einfach nur so.
Prinzipiell, also du hast Recht natürlich, wenn du sagst, ob ich jetzt taktisch oder quasi nur, um quasi den Abzug zu ziehen, in ein Computerspiel schieße. Der Vorgang bleibt derselbe. Aber Untersuchungen von Psychologen haben durchaus ergeben, dass es etwas anderes ist, wenn man selber spielt oder wenn man daneben steht und zuguckt. Und die Art und Weise, wie du es selber rezipierst, ist durchaus eine andere. Ob du siehst oder ob du es selber machst. Und es gibt durchaus Studien, die sagen, dass das taktische Denken, also dieses, welchen Schritt mache ich nach dem anderen? Ich bin selber kein Zocker, ich saß eben so wie es ist. Welchen Schritt gehe ich jetzt vor dem anderen? Welche Strategie habe ich, welchen Plan mache ich? Wesentlich anspruchsvoller fürs Hirn ist und wesentlich andere Dinge in deinem Hirn beansprucht, als nur zu sagen, Feuer, Dauerfeuer, Knopf drücken, fertig.
Also das sind zwei unterschiedliche Geschichten.
Ja genau, genau.
Also ich kann zum Beispiel sagen, ich habe Hitman gespielt, wo ich sage, da kommt es eher auf Taktik an. Auf der anderen Seite habe ich auch Post-Hit gespielt. Bei mir ist der Effekt einfach mal, die Quintessenz ist, ich muss jemanden töten.
Die Quintessenz bleibt natürlich dieselbe, die Mission, die du hast, aber du beschäftigst deinen Kopf mit anderen Dingen. Du stellst dich halt jetzt nicht hin und sagst, du willst sie alle platt machen, sondern du willst da vorrangig eine Aufgabe lösen, einen Rätsel lösen. Aber auch das führt zu weit, da könnt ihr gerne weitermachen im Fritz-Board unter fritz.de. Da wird Sebastian gerne mit euch weiterdiskutieren. Interessante These, weil uns läuft die Zeit weg. Und jetzt kommt Martin Peters drauf mit dem Night Flight. Chaosradio 125 ist damit zu Ende. Danke an Frank, danke Annett, danke an Thorsten. Sehr kontroverses Thema, kann man viel darüber diskutieren. Das werden wir wahrscheinlich auch noch weiterhin machen. Aber nicht mehr jetzt, weil jetzt ist es kurz vor eins. Wir sagen Danke fürs Zuhören. Mehr unter ccc.de. Da gibt es demnächst dann einen Podcast dazu.
Gibt's auch, genau. Und wenn ihr noch Sachen habt, die ihr uns mitteilen möchtet, dann Chaosradio at ccc.de.
Genau. Und ansonsten fritz.de. Immer schön fritz hören, lass dich nicht ärgern. Bis denn.
Tschüss, gute Nacht.